okay
now we're going live can you see and
hear us
can you can you are we live are we
finally there do we make it do it yet
do we make it can you please tell us if
we did it yet
are we [ __ ] alive or not please
are we lying enlighten some some weird
liars
oh my god we're live we're live holy
christ
we've done it this was just the best
assembly process
the last three minutes we thought we
were live and we were like i don't think
we're live
we could be live sometime but you know
we'll get there eventually
oh my goodness thank you so much thank
you to everyone who has been patient
with us
what's funny is that was the most
viewers
that we've gotten to just show up in a
stream
like it was over a thousand so so fast
and then everything crashed i think
youtube was like
not this many people show up in your
live stream so quickly
[ __ ] that you guys we're gonna be taking
shut things down off the line we are
killing this like all right fine youtube
we'll deal with your obstacles jon
figured it all out thank this
[ __ ] right don't thank me
for seriously figuring it all out it
might not have gotten messed up in the
first place had i not
yeah but too close to the sun john
figured it out but guys look
thank you to everyone who's been waiting
thank you to everyone who is patient and
understanding about the [ __ ] that went
wrong
we know we're not the first youtubers to
have [ __ ] crash
you know we're not the first but if you
can go ahead hit that like button that
way people know
that this is not the same stream that
would mean a lot that would be such a
joy
confusion can sometimes happen um so
here's what we're gonna do
because we hop around between just you
know what people are saying in the chat
and please talk amongst yourselves
and then also you know some people send
in super chats and all that we got like
quite a few super chats in the last room
that we didn't get to so we want to
make sure we honor those really quick
and then uh you know resume the stream
as
usual if you guys missed the last part
of the first part of the last stream
i was really raving about how i thought
wonder woman
was the most badass amazonian warrior
that has ever been portrayed out of any
of the film she's featured in
i loved her song that fight that she had
you know what i just realized right now
in this moment
actually uh it hit me when i was
watching it but i didn't make a note of
it
in the in that first fight that she has
wonder woman
uh with the with the heist scene there's
like 10 seconds left on the clock
and i find this movie to be such a cool
build up film like it's it's a great
steady paced build up and she's got 10
seconds left on the bomb
and she is all going in that beautiful
zack snyder slo-mo
and then in 10 seconds she like knocks
everyone out and then when you go to
cyborg's football game
he's got like 10 seconds left on the
clock to finish it
and i think what zack snyder often does
with capturing
the i'm kind of just going into the live
stream aren't i with capturing
um slow-mo of these characters and some
people make fun of zack snyder slo-mo
what i think he does such a great job at
doing
is capturing like the body language and
the internal thoughts in a lot of that
slow motion
and especially like the inner fury
warrior that these characters
are like with wonder woman in that
moment like and then
you especially deal with time frame with
the bomb going off in the finale before
flash has to do time travel
so i actually think there's this really
cool focus on what can be done with
with these warriors and crunch time yeah
that's the christopher nolan influence
for real
i know i think it is i mean i noticed
that if there was a question if i were
to ask zack snyder a question it would
be like
how much of the slow how much of the
handling
of cutting around time in different
characters like i especially noticed
that when like
silas stone gets pulled out of
quarantine and you're cutting back to
steppenwolf silas stone the justice
league
and then when you uh i notice there is a
big influence of time
um and and the handling of it that does
feel like
christopher nolan-esque inspired too you
know mm-hmm absolutely it's the most
nolan-y feeling of all of them and i
feel like you said this while we were
watching it but it was like oh this is
the first time it really makes sense to
me that nolan was a
one of the big producers in his movies
and it helps kick off this iteration of
the universe
yeah yeah man um and i also like that
that that's easy to forget because like
for as much as you know you could say
like well i don't really see his
involvement much across the previous
films like it is kind of cool that he
didn't make it all about himself or
anything like that it's true
all right guys well let's keep this
going all right we on the last stream we
missed some super chats and we want to
make sure those people are not forgotten
so really quick um johnny can you pull
up
those um let me just fix this really
quick
absolutely i can though whatever you're
about to ask okay pull up the super
chest from the last stream so that way
we can make sure we didn't lose those
absolutely possibly absolutely
that might be the best analysis video
tyrone magnus has ever done if you guys
have not seen
tyrone magnus's uh cape flapping video
that was that was the first time i ever
really took notice yeah
hey man this is a hard thing to get
right and capes get a bad rap nowadays
people are all like ah ditch the cape
capes only get you into trouble and and
i think there's uh some love for the
cape yet to come
i know we got quite a bit of uh super
chats in here that we want to make sure
we get to
march the 20th starting right there
there we go and then we'll we'll go
through
these guys but thank you to everyone for
being here and yeah this is gonna be a
long one we're gonna try to talk about
everything we're gonna try and make it
at least as long as the film itself i'm
gonna try to talk about like literally
everything
all right all right we're set to go hey
super chats lookie there look at the old
timey uh
status there well okay some really fun
ones in here thank you alto volte hey
uh thank you alto can i interview you
guys for my channel maybe
hit us up it's possible talk it over
with john the
the manager of everything here that's
true handle it john
i will talk with alto i will appreciate
alto hit me up we'll chat
pcp pop culture podcast is a fantastic
fantastic answer podcast we were both on
it
released the humphrey cut john has a
version cut of the snyder cut that is
one
hour and 30 minutes that's right and and
i left
no [ __ ] season i left in all the
cyborg story and cut out everyone else's
factory
that's the cut i want to see mini rob 2
been with the awesome serrated love you
the raid is a great
film that is the weirdly the film that
launched this channel
brittany lang thank you so much brittany
hey guys long time no chat how are you
guys doing we're doing okay coming up
with the stress of going live
today and yesterday were just the best
days i think in a long time
i appreciate all these super chats guys
but whoever does contribute let's try to
keep it all snyder cut focus
these are all really really generous
thank you and thank you thank you
brittany
um i watched it live your reaction on
patreon
like a hundred people have watched it so
far and that means a lot
yes yeah thank you gub william jones my
favorite two
jesus youtubers people are always
telling us to cut our hair
dude and we just refused a bunch of
[ __ ] about it
have you seen the i am jesus trailer
that's the reaction for you
anissa oliva hey guys at work still uh
but still here
open surprise yet we have not opened the
surprise yet when i tell you i've had a
lot of nights of all-nighters legit had
a panic attack earlier this week
had to talk to my therapist so we are
running behind on some videos we got to
cover
so i want to make sure we do a damn good
snyder cut stream today but thank you
anissa we will do a proper unboxing of
your gift
um gabe campbell it's so weird that it's
all over
four years of oh yeah this is a great
thing to talk about thank you gabe
campbell
it's so weird that it's all over four
years of wishing and hashtags and it's
over
it was all worth it sad we won't see it
continue
restore the snyder verse it is kind of
monumental
in so many ways oh yeah uh unprecedented
because of the fact that
this the journey of this film i am so
excited for when that [ __ ]
documentary comes for this
it's gonna be a damn good documentary of
the ver of
the journey of the snyder cut because
zack snyder
launches man of steel bvs bvs gets
panned right and then there's like a
strong supporter of bvs supporters out
there
and we were part of the the group that
didn't like bvs
uh especially at first and then around
the time
after he lost like uh after he he left
justice league or was pushed out of the
way
and then joss whedon stepped in when you
look at the trajectory of how it all
went
there was this bit even for people who
weren't fans of like the bvs or
something
like people like us who were like but no
he still deserves to get a snyder cut
he still deserves his film and i think
within the time frame of
before i think justice league made
people appreciate his vision more
and i think it also like the joss whedon
one and i think it made a lot of people
go back
people like us who revisited it and then
eventually we're like whoa this is
actually really great and
super deep and powerful yeah we
eventually got there
and a lot of people became bigger snyder
fans and
even throughout the course of the build
up to this there was like there's no way
it could be this good
there's no [ __ ] way snyder cut could
be this good there's no way snyder could
be that's good there's been so much hype
around it yeah it comes out his highest
rated rotten tomatoes movie ever
people are sticking around for four
[ __ ] hours watching this from
beginning to end
absolutely it ends up being one of the
the best or one of the best
of all the dc eu films it's a goddamn
superhero epic it lives up to the hype
it's everything we wanted it to be and a
little bit more
and i'm just like holy [ __ ] there's no
way this movie could have
like lived up to the hype and it has it
is insane it's insane
just how great it is absolutely like it
is in a way the movie itself
like these movies almost reminds me of
the superman arc
in general because it's like you know
justice league we came out superman and
batman ark in general yeah
yeah it's like it came out at first and
we had this weird
rubbery version of it with the weird
upper lip and stuff and then you know
after a while it gets restored into this
big beautiful thing
and and i wonder like part of what i've
been sitting here thinking about in the
past several days
is you know if we had seen the snyder
cut the first time and none of this junk
had ever happened
a lot of the same nuts and bolts would
exist but i wonder
if the movie would feel quite as
heart-wrenching and cathartic i i feel
like in a way
all of this strange circumstance that
led to this and all the anticipation all
the outrage all the
you know hope all those things uh have
kind of made for the
best possible version of this movie
anyway so it's it's been fascinating to
me to think of like
i almost feel like we got the best
version because of all this [ __ ] you
know
yeah it's unfortunate because some
terrible things that happen in the
process
not only zack snyder stepping away but
the passing of his daughter autumn that
which was a big part of why he had to
step away uh to allow himself for him
and his
family to grieve over it so while so
many tragic things have happened
undoubtedly the level of appreciation
for this
would not exist i got all these snyder
cut notes and all these things pulled up
here right now
um oh that's not my notes that's the
other stuff that's the metadata for this
very very find it later
i had some actual notes i made that i
wanted to talk about
but um yeah point being that
this journey has been worthwhile and
it's [ __ ] successful and that makes
me so happy because the worst thing that
could have happened
is it would have been like that was bad
yeah
oh boy clearly having such a shitty
version
really helped out with making this one
more because there are people who
i think see i really loved it the first
time i watched it and i made sure to
watch it the second time i got more from
it the second time
and the first time we watched it we have
a camera pointed us reaction highlights
are being edited it'll be
dished out next week but the second time
i watched it
i picked up on a couple things that i
was like i'm a little nitpicky about
this
but 99.9 of a four-hour film it's pretty
it's pretty perfect for me like i would
i know for sure
i guess my point i'm trying to get at is
even without having
the justice version i would still love
this one
even if that one didn't exist because i
think sometimes people might get a
little confused of like
i know it's like way better than that
one but would i still like this one on
its own
yeah for my personal taste i would still
love this even if that justice league
one didn't exist
absolutely yeah i mean because i feel
like if this had left me cold in ways
that like some of my
less favorite zack snyder movies had i
would still be able to access those
feelings
i feel like the most important thing now
is like yeah this doesn't happen hardly
ever
things like this and a movie that has
like such a story around it that also
kind of
harmonizes with the story within it like
just just as best you can soak
all of this vibe in and remember what it
feels like because these things don't
happen a ton and for the fans who have
been championing this for so long this
has to feel
really great you know and and especially
here and now in the moment where we
don't know if it will
get extended or not you know it's kind
of a beautiful little thing to just
behold and be appreciative of i think i
think zack snyder should release
a version where he includes a few more
minutes like that we live in a society
line
i know we don't live in a society i
thought the line two
of i hear you talk to fish i thought
that was
in the snyder version so i mean he
should release a version with some
alternate takes
or extended takes make it two minutes
longer so we have to sit through all
four hours again
so literally no footage is left on the
cutting room floor let's get all the
ultimate stuff
that's that if you watch the other
trailers we live in a society different
takes
there's some other takes in there that
are not used let's just go
all out here man now i'm sitting here he
shot that just for the trailer he was
just like ah they're gonna freak out
jared leto said that was an improvised
line on his behalf
um incredible tom thank you quality good
fam but i definitely
want to hear your thoughts on the
soundtrack during flash's it's too late
scene
it's a little bit difficult for me to
get very specific about
the soundtrack therefore it's too late
only because i didn't take specific note
of that particular song what i will say
what i will say about the score involved
with this and i feel like john might be
better to comment on it so i'll be quick
about it
the score in general i think one thing
that we are constantly hearing about is
like visual storytelling visual
storytelling
and i think what zack snyder has
captured with them
working in conjunction with the editing
and the music
with junkie xl there's a great music
storytelling to it all
like this the songs not only just
capture the scenes but there's a decent
like by the time you know when it really
hit me with the [ __ ] music
is this like it's all kind of like dark
and epic and harrowing
it was the shot um uh uh change machine
i think is what part four is called
after they talk with gordon and they get
down in the tunnel then they all start
[ __ ] hopping down in a frame like
batman and lightning you got the rock
music going yeah
i'm like [ __ ] there hasn't been this
cool rock music to like two hours into
the movie
because this is when they're becoming
rock stars you know and
i think there's kind of that trajectory
of the music reflecting the scenes
and the overall scope so well like
there's such a variety
and yet they all capture um there's
there's like a if you listen to just the
soundtrack
alone like i did when i worked out last
time
it it feels like you're going on an
emotional journey
just through the songs and so i think
like more than just that one song which
was perfect for that it's too late scene
um the whole movie i thought was perfect
for it yeah absolutely i mean i i really
was impressed by the soundtrack here i
mean because you know i
like in the previous films there is a
sound and a timbre but i feel like
there's a certain
level of uniformity whereas this one
having your ensemble that also have
you know their own themes and whatnot i
thought uh
junkie xl created this really cool
multi-faceted
sound where you had you know like it it
included some of my favorite
use of and interpolations upon like the
wonder woman theme i loved them
going from the guitar to the
vocalization and stuff like that
and you know some of those like mad max
fury road-esque like
synth stabs they would throw in um
yeah i mean this was one that because i
feel like this movie has the widest
spectrum of emotion within it
i feel like the score bring up marvel
characters in a dc stream
yeah what is it humor humors
that kind of release the tension of god
serious discussion gotta have some some
jokes in there gotta
gotta get three shoes let's cram some
re-shot jokes in here yeah
um but yeah yeah yeah that's sweden's
take on it oh boy
uh but yeah i mean i don't like when
flash and cyborg are talking to each
other
in that heartfelt scene where flash says
he was my hero
let's make that a little funnier shall
we yeah why not why
have a moment of actual bonding between
these characters
um yeah though like this reminded me of
kind of a cross
between the scores for like a watchman
and a 300 because 300 has all this very
epic
very traditional music but then it also
has the electric guitar at the right
time where you
want kind of some kind of yeah badass
sort of you know
cockrock riff or something like that and
then it also like that cockroach
yeah this is a real corner of music uh
and and yeah like
you get those sort of have your cake and
eat it two moments but then you
also get a lot of very sort of uh broad
and
uh you know atmospheric music so yeah i
don't know across the board i thought uh
junkie did a great
great job on this he did that was
beautiful
[Music]
and he looks like someone i know taphael
thank you so much for your super chat my
friend
peter pacheco welcome back to live
stream
now restore the snyder verse yes we're
on it
we're working on it guys we're on the
phone with wb
and also a quick question um to the chat
quick quick can we put the super chats
away for a second i got a quick question
for the chat
am i supposed to sign this
day where they sign it it's not actually
yours until you sign it
i should i'm supposed to sign this [ __ ]
i've been wearing this shirt for like
how long three months longer months it's
been since
a little after christmas yeah yeah i've
been wearing it for a while and i
haven't signed it
and i'm like i think i'm supposed to
sign this shirt it's okay
you know take your time only only only
sign it if you if you if you're not
gonna
like if you're gonna wear it out of the
house um
yeah okay just you should twerk though i
see people in the chat want you to twerk
these days
down the splits on a live stream what's
wrong with the trick but i think i mean
at this point i feel like we've
mentioned it quite a bit
i think they absolutely should there's
got to i'm thinking that maybe if we
don't get a direct
zack snyder's justice league too there's
got to be versions of stories he wants
to explore that he can continue on the
snyder verse oh of course
of course the ideal thing would be
can we get zack snyder's justice league
two and three
because this was such a rare case of
what's funny to me is the [ __ ] that
happened in this movie that i i
my journey with the snyder cut has been
there's a lot that i've read up on and
there's a lot that i forgot in the
process of reading up on it
and there were things that i was like
i'm glad i forgot what happens here
because i could feel more surprised one
example can be um wonder woman cutting
off steppenwolf's head
i had no cl i mean and if i if i had
heard that
i must have completely forgotten yeah so
i did not know
steppenwolf's head is cut off by wonder
woman because that was such a beautiful
moment when she
yeah that was just so incredibly badass
especially with the fact
that the first people that you see
steppenwolf
annihilate and attack is the femi the
the
ladies of themyscira certain amazonians
the amazons the females the feminists
the amazon glorious ladies of
wrestling um those are the first people
you see
uh them just uh steppenwolf attack and
destroy
so for her to get the final kill and
then his
head to pop through the boom tube and
dark side not even a second thought just
crushes his head like he's nothing a
peasant
like you think steppenwolf was tough
thanks darkseid's the real [ __ ]
threat thanks for saving me a step
so that shot i did not know about where
she cuts off his head
point being i knew a lot of what was
supposed to be featured in here
and there's a difference between you
know how people talk about like the
colin trevero version like that would
have been a better
uh uh star wars movie we don't know that
for sure
we don't sometimes sometimes things just
sound better in in thought or concept
art and then your mind fills in the
blanks you're like yeah that will be
better and maybe it will be and i'm i'm
likely to think that colin trevorrow
version would have been better
for snyder cut so much of what i knew
would happen
did happen and yet i still felt
surprised and yet i did find it
refreshing
and yet i was still moved to tears and
yet i still cheered
and so it's kind of strange to get a
movie where so much that you know
of plot points that are supposed to take
like silas stone dying
knew about that and still broke my heart
when he died yeah absolutely like
it casts a new emotional sheen over the
entire experience yeah so like every
moment can hit you in a new way because
it's not playing on the same
feelings that the theatrical cut was
even if the moments are based on the
same events you know
and my long-ass point that i'm getting
to with all this
is that what makes it so great
when um what makes it so great about the
idea of getting zack snyder's justice
league two and three is that he has the
storyboards out and the outlines out
and you're like yes i want to see
exactly that
that's the snyder verse i want to see
and i think it's just such a weird
neat position to be in of like no we
know exactly what you want to do
we just want to see that fulfilled yes
and how great is that like how exciting
is that because
he has to deliver on on that the
storyboards and the outlines but then
also give us
fresh stuff along the way and uh so yeah
absolutely i want the snyder verse
oh yeah yeah yeah do it i got a lot of
thoughts obviously i was very moved i'm
sorry john
hey john why don't you tell them thank
you christianity i've been talking so
much
why don't you just say all right take
away the flash reversing time moment
is goated that was one of my very very
favorite moments in the movie and uh
it's funny i i think dan murrell even
said this in his review but it was it
was a moment that i was surprised to
find myself
choking up during because it really
did just transport me into that
catharsis of like
barry you're the only one who can fix
this now and also it's like he has to
reach
further and dig deeper than he ever has
before and
yeah like the catharsis of that moment
and the way
they orchestrated it with like just the
world re-materializing at his feet and
all the electricity flying around like
it was a moment where i was
dazzled and it's like yeah there's tons
of cg
in tons of movies they can make any kind
of dazzles nobody can have peace
but yeah that was a moment that was
a true blue instance of like wow
that's something new like that's
something that's a new experience that
wowed me
in a way that i haven't been wowed in a
little while and uh
i am so so so so glad that they included
that yeah i think that's one of the best
superhero movie moments period i think
one of
that whole like uh obviously what i'm
what we do
is sometimes we might not get a direct
question about something but we'll take
your question and use it to maneuver
into other answers
so manipulate your question to our own
ends like the flash reversing time
moment
i've seen the first five seasons of the
flash so i'm familiar with the flash
thing yeah i know this is saying i'm
familiar with the plot point
of the flash either using time travel to
make things better or to [ __ ] up
everything
you know and i've seen like justice
league flashpoints so like the
familiarity of flash being able to time
travel
on on at least on live action television
which is cw which is nowhere near the
levels of the zack snyder film someday
but even on cw it was like it's pretty
cool that they're doing this
what what i think is so effective about
the flash reversing time moment too that
that i think is not acknowledged enough
because not only is it epic in scope and
what he's doing in terms of plot point
and saving the day
you get two complete character arcs back
to back in that moment
well you get superman who shows up not
impressed when the axe falls on him
right and then um when uh everything is
blown to smithereens everyone's dying
flash in that moment he has his
character arc
it comes to fruition completion from
what you set up in his time with talking
with henry allen in prison
about um you know you you can make your
own future you can make your own past
that he's like he could do whatever and
with his dad not being aware that he has
flash powers
so you could literally
get it you can literally do this you're
the flash
go on but in that moment his his a
realization of
most potential comes to life of what his
father was trying to instill in him
in that very beat when he does the time
trial that's what makes it so powerful
it's not just a cool moment it's a
character arc coming to completion and
then it's
[ __ ] segways like a beautiful
[ __ ]
into cyborg's character all right touch
us inside we're just jacked in the
mother box
i'm not broken [ __ ] beautiful and
that's what makes the like the
completion of you get that you just get
so much happening in that superman shows
up
takes on steppenwolf they don't what i
love too is that it wasn't just we
needed superman okay thank god he's
doing everything
like he does most of the heavy lifting
but other people do [ __ ] you know
aquaman stabbing him [ __ ] wonder
woman cutting off his head other people
do stuff in that fight
and then flash and then cyborg so you're
getting this completion tale of all
three
in this beautiful finalized action set
piece and that's what makes this so
powerful
yeah and i think that like the
storytelling mixed in with zack snyder's
beautiful visuals
and detail for action choreography for
unique set of powers
boom boom tube
i'm just pandering guys i really don't
feel this way it's just a bunch of
[ __ ] joss whedon's
i didn't actually watch it feel any of
this it's all lies
i watched it on double it's all live
yeah i watched it on double speed i was
like man just too slow
not too many music videos don't just be
an [ __ ] and clip that
and this is also a great example of why
john and greg take too long to uh get
through super chats
i don't know what you're talking about i
was a guy on patreon who was having
trouble oh louis is your patron
thank you louis oh you have no i loved
your reaction cheered and cried along
with you too yeah full length
on patreon we can sync up with us
reaction highlights working on being
edited for this week
thank you thank you buddy that [ __ ] was
took so long to assemble because
we saw other reactors divide it yeah
and john and i were like no let's just
do it in one gallon
you know it seems like it would
ultimately it'll present certain
challenges but it ultimately be easier
than having to like jump to four
different streams i was thinking about
the sink too for people i'm like
yeah it's already enough to keep one
video in sync and then to do it four
other times to be a lot
uh about manage you i'm glad you managed
to get it working
you have no idea how much that stressed
me out when i saw your comments so thank
you lewis yeah dude really happy you got
to enjoy it here we go
juicy question julian rodriguez love you
guys and your personalities thank you
julian
what are your thoughts on the nightmare
joker scene and where are the m
m reactions got a joker playing poker
and with the green hair and his
underwear with the
big cam bears damaged in the
damage of the forehead and
[ __ ] lois is dead uh
not to the nightmare joker scene oh i
kind of touched on it briefly in the
stream that failed uh john why don't you
uh why don't you take this one away
first
i i mean that's a sequence in which i
i understand a lot of the gripes that
people have levied against it in terms
of it's feeling
like one of the more there's just the
things that
fit less smoothly and coherently into
the overall flow of the movie i
i don't begrudge the movie the sequence
or the joker uh
uh appearance whatsoever because i
enjoyed it you know like it worked for
me it was the fan service that you know
it was intended to be
however if i'm going strictly
objectively
there are elements of that scene that
very much feel like somebody got the
chance and didn't know if they would
ever get the chance again so they put
them in
but i like what they promise and it's
the kind of thing where it's like if
they were to continue
then i would be glad that the scene is
in there because then it's going to be
further developed upon and whatnot so
it's like
it's another one of those things that it
seems pretty clear
was not part at least as we see it now
of the original
zack snyder justice league and so i'd
take it rather than not taking it
but i do understand the uh you know
critique
that it is like another ending on top of
a bunch of other endings that are a lot
more graceful
you know my biggest i'll talk about the
joker in a second but my biggest
takeaway in that
were two things first thing ben affleck
i'm like you mean to tell me this guy
doesn't want to play batman anymore
look how [ __ ] good he's doing yeah
look how good he did this is the re-shot
[ __ ]
yeah he's doing so good yeah um
like so good what i thought was cool is
you know bruce in this movie
in zack snyder's justice league is very
um he's different than the batman and
bvs he's more hopeful
yeah uh he's got more faith these are
exact words that he says
well he seems like he's learned and
considered his actions of the previous
films
exactly that's what's cool exactly uh to
to jump into
this with him because bruce wayne has
clearly um
learned and he has grown already so he's
got a little bit more of a
optimistic attitude and it's not just
like i [ __ ] hate everyone
but my favorite bruce wayne performance
and honestly even after zach's
i love what ben affleck does in here
don't get me wrong i love it i still
would say
his performance in bvs is my favorite
bruce wayne batman performance
but what's cool about that nightmare
scene with bruce i'm like oh he's like a
hybrid of the bbs
and the and what we got in zack snyder's
like he's still playing team leader
like i'll work with deathstroke i'll
work with joker
but i still go i got a much rougher edge
about me than what you saw i don't know
i'm not gonna pretend like i do like
even when martian manhunter shows up i'm
like that's the optimistic joker
optimistic batman right there that's the
optimistic batman we've hung out with
yeah that's not the one we got in the
nightmare version that's not the i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you
batman the other thing i got to was man
amber heard is not nailing that british
accent
no no i liked it in the first scene and
when she came back in the nightmare i
was like what happened
no don't like i loved her look i thought
her look was cool
yeah and i when she first did her
british accent we were both like
it actually works kind of performance
yeah but when the reshoot were
like i don't know about this something
went wrong
you should have brought the dialect
coach back to help you brush up
um but in terms of joker in terms of
jared leto um
the first time we watched it i i thought
i was so
in awe of how much better it was to me
than it was compared to what we saw of
the theatrical cut of suicide squad
notice i'm saying theatrical cut because
i believe one day we will get it
and i am definitely championing for that
but
um i was so in awe of that on my second
time i watched it
my main takeaway wasn't with him was
actually not the handling of his lines
but i was really impressed with
his uh the moments where he's just kind
of like eerily quiet and
and watching and studying and looking
like
kind of descending you know actually he
felt like a joker that was embodying the
fact that this is a nightmare for batman
yeah you know like that's where i felt
like jared leto's performance was really
honing in on and the way how
zack snyder shoots that like really up
close and handheld and personal
and a lot of like shots where joker is
just completely out of focus
or obscured by light flare yeah yeah so
i thought like
i it's very apparent that what jared
leto was doing
was what zack snyder wanted him to do
you know
which was like oh it's so great to see
his performance
in unison with a director this
is so refreshing well and with a movie
that seems like it wants to include him
rather than
trying to cut him out as much as
possible yeah yeah and i mean i loved
his
i just liked his presence a lot and like
you know i feel i feel like marilyn
manson joker is a joker take i would
like to see
i think it's the take plucking that
version into like the future because
what did we learn today like i actually
didn't really know about
what's supposed to happen in justice
league two and three until very very
recent
um so what did we learn that like
joker uh he can he's the one who has the
mother boxes he's like stolen the mother
box or whatever so he can do the time
travel to give the flash
yeah right right lois it's the curry
lois
i mean it would be cool to see him man
[ __ ] great
was cool to see the flash's uh you know
the the like armor
helmet you know outfit come back to and
pay off that uh sequence from bbs you
know
thank you julian uh pop culture podcast
he's cp
he's asking um are we still live i'm
always i'm very paranoid that we're
gonna
we're gonna go where are we all right
um all right where are we at we are here
it is now there's one comment in here
that someone's said that
his his girlfriend sighs every time he
puts on in one of our videos
don't worry my fiance's size the second
i start to record and everyone
sighs when i walk in a room
pop culture podcast what are some
elements that were in the snyder cut
that remind you of avengers endgame or
infinity war hit me up on instagram
after the live if you can love to get
you both on the podcast soon get us both
on there
really had us as individuals that would
be your avengers assembled there
elements are reminded us of snyder that
reminders of avengers and game or
infinity war
i mean i don't know there's nothing
really like just the fact that they're
superhero teemo movies
there was nothing really here that made
me go oh that you know what did make me
think
actually steppenwolf getting his head
cut off
the big baddie yeah like that thor did
not go for the head
yes
yeah that's one element right there that
i think
um definitely hits honestly that's so
different
the mood and tone and style is is so
wildly different
yeah i got a similar feeling of
catharsis
and of like triumphant relief
during the scene yeah where um uh barry
is you know like running faster than
ever and he's about to go and help
cyborg like that moment
felt like thanos had won and then we had
just
you know finally figured out the way to
inch it back into the right timeline and
so like
while it didn't remind me of end game
necessarily
in a structural or a plot points kind of
way
that was the one thing that definitely
took me to that place of like
wow this really does feel like a huge
grave moment for the universe we have
lost like it is bad
oh wait barry's putting it all back
together
non-snap things like that's that that
was kind of how that how that felt so
like
and and that moment like the reason i
think why is because
for a lot of these movies you feel some
loss you feel peril but end game
in infinity war and then this took it to
a level of like
oh man the heroes lost
yeah and then brought it back so like
that yeah that's it for me i mean that's
kind of what's so great about it uh
i guess with the journey and kind of
mirroring each other is that i think
what zack snyder can do a really great
job at doing is starting off a movie on
such a bleak note and ending on such a
hopeful note
this one most of all yeah starts off
really i mean bvs same thing it's very
bleak and then ends on a hopeful note
yeah yeah and so i think yeah yeah i
mean i guess
this one having to bring back people to
take on the big baddie
threat it's kind of like bringing back
superman but i don't know
it's just it's execute like if you if if
you go down to such basic plot points
then yeah i guess it's kind of similar
but not really and i like it doesn't
feel or play out or tonally like
they're they're so opposite from each
other yeah that i i can't really compare
them
well in their universes where like by
the time you get to endgame and infinity
war like the super activity in the
marvel universe is like
such the standard of living whereas in
this justice league universe it seems
like this is the most
super-powered activity we've seen thus
far i mean like there's been mass
destruction but now you have like a
whole team of heroes
and you've also got you know
intergalactic evil coming your way
so you gotta say it's so great to be
talking about this movie yeah yeah
that's
okay i know instead of just like
listening to reviews in the off time
it's thick enough
to where you could just talk about this
for so long oh yeah you can just jump in
on so many different angles
but thank you pcp peter pacheco great
video thank you peter
um appreciate that great video about the
actress with cyborg yeah
you guys haven't seen that i was not
expecting to get that emotional from for
like five straight minutes like
i'm just talking about one [ __ ]
moment in time and hey not a lot of
people talked about it too like i saw a
lot of people being like damn i wouldn't
have known if you got
if you hadn't chosen to do that video
and that was that was a good call
in case you guys haven't seen that video
i mean what happened is that lady
who in the atm scene where uh cyborg
does full robin hood with giving her a
hundred thousand dollars
she did not know if her scene was
restored or not
and she um i think it lived in a part of
the world that couldn't access hbo max
can remember i think london
anywhere outside of the continental
united states
yeah so she looked at the spot where she
couldn't access it and then she found
out that people were praising her scene
so much and that scene moved me to tears
absolutely
the parts that got me the most pissed
off for not including
that which you know there's been a lot
of opinions about ray fisher
as a late there's a lot of people who
[ __ ] defend the [ __ ] out of him
and there are a lot of people who are
like who come down on him yeah
you know and then i think a lot of and i
think a subconscious factor that some
people were
were saying because from day one even
with justice league
john and i have always been like weirdly
know cyborg was one of my favorite parts
of that movie even though i hear a lot
of his [ __ ] was cut he's one of my
favorite parts
some people thought he was nothing or
nobody like didn't make leave an impact
at all
a lot as a matter of fact a lot of
reviews that i'm hearing of zack
snyder's justice league are people
saying
i didn't care at all about cyborg but i
cared about him the most here
yeah but think about that just think
about that first
when this movie comes out and you hear
zack snyder's been saying he's the heart
of the story
you hear how pissed off ray fisher is
about uh
with the kind of abuse that joss whedon
displayed on set
and also just to be affected by the fact
that so much of your great stuff was cut
out of the film
yeah and you hear that and then the
evidence is there when this movie comes
out
i'd be like [ __ ] accountability over
entertainment yeah i'm all for but
let's push all the abuse stuff out to
the side all right like we shouldn't
i'm just saying for this moment in time
of this 30 seconds of a conversation
let's push it to the side
just the fact that this [ __ ] was cut out
that scene with your football game
looking up and seeing your dad not in
the stands
when he is crying in the car with his
mom
everything with his mom with his like
that look that he has i'm like okay yeah
this is a
kind of uh yeah i've seen this scene
before you're upset that your dad didn't
show up at the football game
i've seen this scene before but then
when he looks over and you see him
crying i'm just like
[ __ ] that's heartbreaking yeah and then
the car crashes
and when he is starting to embrace his
cyborg powers
when he zips up in the air like he's
figuring out how to fly
in that little smile across a little
smile like damn that is so
moving i am so upset why why it upsets
me
that it's cut is because you could have
fit this [ __ ] in that justice version
at least at minimum you could have fit
this in there
it's a few important minutes of this
character
that you could have fit in that version
and so it pissed me off that none of
this was in there
yeah it doesn't make any sense like it
it objectively does not make
sense in a lot of ways because it just
takes away all of your investment in
that character
yeah i don't know it was uh it's it
seems
especially hanky because because it does
happen it seems like
inordinately to cyborg in that
theatrical cut but
i mean even if you can't get uh zack
snyder's justice league too or
given the situation that's happening
with cyborg and ray fisher with his uh
with walter hamada i feel like there's
got to be something where you can get
cyborg to be in
in like his own hbo max movie or
something like that like i
would hope so like there's too much good
work there's too much good work in there
not to
yeah let it live beyond that
yeah i love his arc so much it's so
powerful
so powerful um thank you peter pacheco
timinator songs appreciate that buddy
appreciate that
jeff nelson hey guys love
the channel reactions what do you think
the consequences will be
for barry for going back in time we'd
love to talk to you all sometime love to
talk to you too jeff thank you for the
super chat buddy
the consequences will be for barry going
back in time
i feel like that plays into everything
that was supposed to happen in zack
snyder's justice league two and three
mm-hmm
the any time there's got to be
consequences if there's one thing that
we've learned from all movies but
especially with flash stories
he should not like literally as
beautiful and heroic as a moment as it
is
i've seen enough of properties about the
flash
to go something bad's gonna happen doing
this yeah yeah
the other shoe is gonna drop and
someone's gonna collect the bill for you
fixing
that yeah and it's kind of ironic
because
the most like limited of ironic usage
but
superman christopher reeves he turns
back time to save the day yeah
i think there's always a ripple effect
that's going to occur that as much as he
might do something great
i can't tell you specifically my theory
my theorizing is just not
calibred enough to be able to give you a
good theory here
um but i do think that whatev
if we do get zack snyder's justice
league two and three i feel like there
will be immediate consequences for what
he had undone
there is something that goes wrong every
time you [ __ ] with the timeline
especially in the case of barry allen no
matter how heroic
it is him [ __ ] up the timeline [ __ ]
something up
you know well that's a great i think
it's gonna segue into flashpoint yeah
i think they're gonna i wonder i wonder
if flashpoint will
operate because you know this is not
canon with dc eu
but i'm like it would just make more
sense to work within the canon of zack
snyder's movie wouldn't it
absolutely it seems like yeah
i don't know yeah i mean that seems like
the kind of thing that you would
definitely i would definitely want to
use as a part of the direct driving
motion of the next couple films because
yeah it only makes sense and uh
yeah it only makes sense it's like you
can't undo something
so huge that's also got to do with like
dimensions crossing or at least like
worlds linking together
you just can't get away from that
without a consequence and i like the
idea
for barry of like a triumphant moment
because that's that's kind of life
sometimes you triumph in one area but
then you find out that there are still
consequences for that triumph that could
create
problems down the line and so yeah i
feel like that would be a great place to
bed
some of the conflict if they do get to
revisit justice league in a future
installment
um so i mean omni media in this in the
chat who by the way did his own live
stream earlier
it's actually a good thing our live
stream crashed so it doesn't conflict
with your conflict with yours because i
think we run live around the same time
oh hey you sabotaged us but omni media
was saying
are there different consequences for
skipping points in time as opposed to
reversing time
i think no matter what like you mess
with the order of timeline
doctor who taught us that it wasn't
supposed to play this way you were
supposed to die
anything there's a consequence there has
to be otherwise barry could do that
every time
yeah there has to be a there'd be no
peril if barry could just reverse time
there has to be a negative effect that
occurs or else
like well [ __ ] barry just rewind time
would you like
that's everyone would be coming to be
like hey dude sorry can you fix this
really quick
yeah we accidentally fill in the blank
we ripped a hole in space-time we killed
a bunch of people in a city who knows
you know
that's what i'm saying but thank you
jeff correct science is not impressed
breeze breath axe freeze breath axe
okay yes so so oh okay oh you're
quoting the movie yeah yeah yeah i was
like
i am not impressed by this stream it's
the weirdest thing to come in here
please i'm a super chat yeah not
impressed inhale a bottle of axe and
choke yourself to death
i've i'm remembering okay just a heads
up in my reaction
i do say like i don't think he does it
in the last one
but what i was saying was i don't think
he does that in bvs or man of steel
but in the justice one he does do it now
i'm remembering that now
but it's still great because i forget
what the what's the [ __ ] line that he
says in the justice when he shows up is
like
oh i'm a big fan of justice too or
something yeah
that's like a big sentence someone says
something about truth and then he's like
but i'm also a big fan
i'm all for truth but i'm also a big fan
of justice it's like
so cheesy gonna be the show up there
and then when he shows up here it's so
unexpected and just
not impressed but [ __ ] superman
was so brutal it was just like
so brutal like man you must really not
like this guy he just they woke him up
from the dead on this guy's behalf it
was like equivalent to the
drive-stomping head scene
if you guys haven't seen drive ryan
gosling stomps a guy's head in an
elevator
spoilers so it was like that
it got to the point where i'm like
you're being kind of a little mean
superman you are
angry right now like it's so bad it's
just
laser laser he just won't stop
well he's got exact same fists like stay
the [ __ ] down
stay the [ __ ] down every time i gotta
imagine that in that moment he's
probably processing a lot of catharsis
from this life and the previous one
because it seems like almost when
like when someone pushes you too far in
a physical scenario but then all the
baggage you've been storing up comes out
that's kind of how that felt to me
i've been dead for a while i'm not dead
i got killed i gotta get some
energy [ __ ] doomsday like all this
other stuff
like yeah i gotta just [ __ ] let go i
gotta let loose i'm sick of your people
[ __ ] coming here
and somehow it's linked to me tired of
these people
the tangle of their lives pcp
thank you craig man of steel is the best
ecu film changed my mind that's your
opinion can't change your mind
man um you're allowed to have your
opinion what i would say though is i
think it's beautiful that's
this a lot of people kind of fail to
realize that
this this is really superman's whole arc
yeah is these three movies and every
thing that has happened is all
linked to superman like i love the
opening of this
oh yes haunting was that just so
such a great setup the this the booms of
his screams
alerting the mother box and the people
of apocalypse you know
yeah and just and you're going to all
these different parts of the world where
the mother boxes are located
the echo of the screams and it's like
man of steel's about superman alone
the events uh batman v superman's about
batman and superman but
a lot of what occurs because of lex
luthor the creation
of doomsday everything is and then the
the the consequences of what it means to
have a superman in our world
every and then of course the death his
sacrifice is what leads to
all the events of justice league and
then he is the hero in the end
the one who can help help him help them
defeat the day
this is supe these movies are really
superman's movies
yeah even though this is the one he's
the least in it is it is superman's
movie
so much is intrinsically tied to him and
and clark undergoes a lot of growth as
different characters are added in and
forced to interact with him it's like in
the first movie he's on his own learning
and just how to be
this super powered person here on earth
amongst all these other people unlike
you
then the second one it's like okay now
what happens when you move into a bigger
fishbowl where there are people like you
and they're not
happy about you and then the third one
it's like okay
then you learn how to fully exist in
this world and you also find your allies
and your people and yeah there's like a
full-on
it made me appreciate the previous two
snyder films that much more because even
still like having
revisited them and lead up to this there
are still elements that feel and not
even in a complaint kind of way like it
it makes sense for those movies to feel
a little colder and a little more
detached
but what i appreciated so much was this
and especially through clark
really showed the growth of and
formation
of the hopeful warmth you want from
superman and it just took
these arcs of the story to get there and
that was
beautiful to me absolutely 100 agree i
mean really quick
because i'm gonna go on a tie tangent
here do it i think the
i think with some people some of the
criticism that i've thrown in the past
um until like watching ultimate edition
and then revisit like i've really grown
to understand
uh in the past like a couple of years
two to three years of what zach cena
does with his characters
it's very easy to criticize especially
like some theatrical cuts of his
of his characters and go his movies are
like they're great visuals
yeah he pulls out pages that are like
from the panels
but his characters are always just kind
of brooding and one-dimensional and i
don't think that's the case at all
i feel like each one of these characters
especially demonstrated in justice
league
but in the bvs ultimate edition too
man of steel is what all them like
underneath it all
every character has a lot of heart and
it's a lot it's a journey
for these characters about i think what
it mainly boils down to
is journeys of overcoming trauma
loneliness
and learning to accept thyself yeah i
think that's what they always come down
to
i mean just look at flash in here look
at cyborg look at superman
all their journeys have been about
self-acceptance
and learning to not how to not be alone
like that's wonder woman's journey in
this justice league film how
how to open herself back up again
aquaman
same thing that's all these characters
and and superman like while a lot of
their journeys are kind of told in this
one movie superman's just
told over the course of three films yeah
yeah um it's cool so yeah
i like that yeah man and i get it
and i get his movies it's just so weird
to be like three years ago this is not
my opinion
and then to be like [ __ ] mind blown
i'm like
oh my god i think that's the powerful
effect of of zach's
i think that's why zack snyder kind of
gets this
this feeling of almost religious cultish
vibe around him yeah
is because it's that kind of journey
with his movies that when you don't get
it you really don't get it and you don't
like it
but when you feel his movie when you
suddenly feel it when it gets in here
you become like a devotee
to his vision you know yeah i mean
that's what occurs
there's yes there's something so
expressive and almost
romantic in the way that he forms the
films and he is good
at putting you in the emotional space of
a character or the mood of a scene
especially and making that
permeate heavily so uh yeah and it's
funny because to
like it's sort of strange to see over
such a wide breadth because if you watch
a season of a show and a story develops
that's one thing
but when you're watching a story develop
over movies that take several
years to get a new installment of yeah
you know i think it's easy then to not
have justice league feel one way then
get justice league and feel very
differently
um and i think that yeah having i think
this one shines
the brightest and clinches that the
brightest because you have all the other
characters
who get to show that just different
motivations and different
aspects of the heart that are coming out
and so
having them there to harmonize i thought
was really nice and it made a lot more
sense
finally having seen justice league at
how they especially the whole complaint
about like
ah you should have done a bunch of solo
movies and then built up to your
crossover like there's still merit to
the argument for that but looking at at
least these three movies and a couple of
the other dcu films i'm like oh this
actually does kind of make sense as
you know you're introducing the world
and you're packing more characters on
with each installment but you're still
keeping the development going for what
you already
put in there previous right and so yeah
it does feel like a thing that grows
naturally by the end of it in a
fascinating way
if you guys are enjoying the stream can
you hit the like button i see a lot of
questions and this is to be expected
during a stream
there's a lot of questions that are
coming in the live chat right now
but just know that our style tends to be
you might ask a question and then we
kind of go around
we'll find zigzag and a bunch of bunch
of different corners here
eventually people who are asking like
what do you think about jared leto's
joker no we did a whole spiel on jared
leto's joker
earlier in this stream so yeah this is
meant this is the first live stream
we're doing that's really meant to be
like uh
played back in some ways yeah devin do
you think the flash at the end was in
the speed force or the earth was getting
destroyed there looked like outer space
i think it was in the speed force
he talked about how he's in the speed
force when he's when he's first talking
with bruce wayne
how he activates it i'm pretty sure it
was a hundred percent the speed force
that's the only thing that makes sense
as to how we did it all
yeah i think everything's getting
obliterated around him in slow in slow
motion
you know but thank you devon peter
pacheco
um and now let's continue with this with
the injustice story which the nightmare
referenced
i think it's a lot easier to get on
board with what zack snyder does too
when especially if you pl
if you've read or even played the
injustice games
um and the injustice versions you get
like all kinds of evil takes on these
characters
yeah it's great it's fantastic so yeah
man uh
what's in justice three coming out gotta
play that jason brown broad
broad big fan of our content um
thoughts on the reveal of martian
manhunter i got some thoughts here hey
now we're in we're finally talking about
martian man finally doing harry lennox
some justice there
i thought it was really cool that
martian manhunter was finally affirmed
to be in this movie i thought it was
great
but um i do think
it's weird i mean i talked about it
earlier on a video that is blocked
worldwide right now so
i tried getting a video up earlier and
it got blocked but
um martian man hunter i i love the scene
between him and martha kent
uh martha kent and and lois lane because
i think if that wasn't martian martian
manhunter it would it would still work
equally as well if it wasn't martian
manhunter
but you see in bvs how harry lennox um
uh
swanwick takes a liking to lois lane
like he's doing things that
people in the military shouldn't be
doing to help out this reporter
but he obviously takes a certain amount
of liking and trust
and dear mentor more than most people
would
so to have that confirmation of like yes
he was
martian manhunter the scene's kind of
funny in context of like
because it's easy to look at that scene
and go i just want you to work at the
daily planet lois
i miss your articles lois i don't have
anything to read anymore lois
but it's about more than that he's
helping a friend get back on her feet
and
and helping her to move on you know
someone he cares about yeah and someone
who who actually makes an impact on the
world from the human level
the scene at the end does feel like it's
only there to set up a sequel yes it
does
it does feel that way so in that kind of
cynical context
yeah i could see that as terms of like
it doesn't really complete the movie it
sets up the sequel for something that
we're gonna have to fight to get
but in the traditional fashion of how
sometimes
you have things in a zack snyder movie
where you're like i don't really know
about needing this i don't know if this
really works
and then he does a sequel and then
you're like okay in the grand scheme of
your one
epic tale this really works now and i
think the same can be applied if we end
up successfully getting
another another version another um what
you may call it uh zack snyder's justice
league with martian manhunter and it'll
be like all right now it really works
right now that ending bit kind of feels
like sequel setup only
i still think he looks great like he
looks awesome
yeah it's it's still like a visually
dazzling look
like damn you know i i'm always more of
a fan of practical effects but
in terms of cg it looks incredible and
i'm just excited at the thought of
possibly getting some real martian man
hunter
uh thrown in the mix and so yeah it
would be cool to see him like interact
one time with clark but you know
and i think too like when i watch man of
steel i don't really see martian
manhunter and harry lennox's performance
but i really see martian manhunter
in the bvs performance i could see that
there yeah that's fair
what'd you think of martian manhunter
john i thought i i agree with you i mean
i really liked
especially his the the piece of context
in the present there for when he goes
and visits lois and whatnot
i i i was weirdly the detail i zeroed in
on was
oh he embraces his nickname he just yeah
he just they call me the martian man
hunter okay well all right but yeah i
mean i i really
like i mean i was somebody who in the
spider-man
sam raimi universe was always really
jazzed about like oh they're building up
dylan baker to be the lizard
and this is kind of these movies version
of that in a different flavor and
yeah i mean i thought it was cool to
finally see him in the get-up and it was
one of those things where i'm like
because of the special event this is
it's not that big of a deal to me that
this does feel something like you know
just a tease for the future
um but yeah i don't know i mean i
thought it was a very satisfying
sequence i really like the design and
the way that they realize the design
because it's not you know like a hundred
percent the design from the comics but
you can definitely
see it in there and yeah it just it just
fuels this conflicted feeling of like
that makes me excited for the future of
which
i am not in at all certain that it will
even exist in the fashion we got a zack
snyder's justice league
movie at all that it seemed more likely
even zack snyder said himself recently
that it seemed more likely that they
might even offer to let him do justice
league too more than it would be to let
him restore
zack snyder's justice yeah you know so
there's a possibility what i want to
touch
i saw this coming up in the chat uh in
the livestream chat just now
about um about uh what you may call it
oh yeah we should talk about the batman
[ __ ] kill you london
but also um people were talking about
how
batman is has like premonition skills
ah and with the martian manhunter reveal
i want to touch on the batman
premonition stuff
okay because it is that's i think that's
kind of what makes it a little funny
especially the fact that he like has
this nightmare
he's just like terrible nightmare and
then immediately he's visited by an
alien
alien he's kind of optimistic about it
like hey
who are you supposed to be well he
wasn't in the dream so he doesn't have
any reason to be
kind of just used to weird [ __ ]
happening you're a fresh face who are
you
you could have been sent by lex luthor
but i'm not gonna i'm not even gonna ask
i just love that he has these
premonition skills that are not being
honed in on like
ben affleck uh uh bat sense when he's
got the bad sense
when when he is um talking with wonder
woman
uh batman and he's like i had a dream
almost like a premonition
barry showed up told me lois is the key
he's like telling her about this
premonition
and she's just like well lois is the key
looks like she is
and i'm like wait so we're not going to
talk about it all that you had a
premonition
about like about the dream and
everything like that
you're not going to possibly ruminate on
that was one of my nitpicks i have like
three nitpicks with this movie and one
of my nitpicks was
how come you're not honing in and not
all that he's having premonitions and
then he has like another premonition
later on in this movie and i'm like are
we gonna explore
are we gonna explore the fact at all
because cyborg has his premonitions
uh the visions of what will happen uh
moments before
flash activates the mother box to
resurrect superman right and that one
makes more sense considering
what they're doing yeah whereas batman's
having kind of these random premonitions
and um you know i'm like is that going
to be explored
does this barry allen's time travel have
something to do with i feel like there's
a justification to the premonitions not
that you can just
see the future there's got to be a
justification of like worlds crossing or
some
[ __ ] like that that are conflicting with
his timeline of being bruce wayne or
something you know yeah or something i
mean because yeah there's not really a
lot allowed in that scene for it but you
would think that he'd draw some kind of
connection between like oh yeah
flash came in and pierced through time
and space to contact me
in that suit that he's wearing in my
nightmare from just now
yeah yeah well if you guys haven't um
done this right already can you go ahead
and hit that like button
if you have been enjoying the stream i
would really mean a lot to me
but thank you benny kenobi you two are
amazing
huge fan of yours also really love this
movie so i'm glad i could watch on crave
in canada hope this helps benny kenobi
it undoubtedly helps shout out to canada
one day we will visit there thank you
thank you uh jean jeter tv you are live
congrats you owe youtube 50 000 live
stream guys
50 000 new worlds that lying in there
and that look on steppenwolf's face
i was just like do you know how hard it
is to conquer around the world
this is not gonna live that long ever
never gonna live that long you owe me
1550
000 worlds unless you can collect a
couple worlds in bulk it's never going
to work out like what did you do
what did you do yeah how 50 000 worlds
just how far up did you did you [ __ ] up
because this is this is fathom
parkside standards this is unreasonable
a hundred worlds is a lot you're being
ridiculous
yeah 50 000 worlds he'll never hit this
goal you're setting him up to fail
it's like sentencing someone to like 10
life sentences like
i'm never going to fill this what do you
get out of this
one thing i'll get out of the way too is
that i what i love about steppenwolf's
redesign are his eyes
there's so much humanity in his eyes
he's [ __ ] lonely and sad
like when he has the armor on he is
lethal and you do not
[ __ ] with this guy but when he does not
have his armor on
he's just like a sad being on your head
is lonely and heartbroken his armor
carries most of his identity
it seems like just like the look that he
at least smells of the confident i did
any time to solder dark side give him
information he's just
okay all right all right this is a lot
to
process yeah man he's in over his head
he lives a shitty life
love this she's a tragic character nash
thank you uh gene nash and not key love
this challenge
thank you for my friend appreciate it
nash is just like a bitchin name
nashville 1950's name you're in the most
recent uh patron name
call out so keep the lookout for that
mustafa
jav best green lantern movie
hands down probably absolutely
i mean hey it's nice to have that direct
acknowledgement in this universe
even if it's not ryan reynolds darkseid
gave him jake clemons in the chat
darkseid gave him a disc guy he still
couldn't pull it off
first i never forgot i was typing won't
be used as a
[ __ ] with him as a baby oh man
so uh what do mustafa say here
let's say here uh best green lantern
movie too okay so what i found out
is actually and i noticed this on the
rewatch that there's two green lanterns
here
one of them is kilowog who's in the
green lantern
ryan reynolds movie and the other one is
the person i don't know
i don't know what that is my green
lantern lore is all over the place i
don't really know it
but there's two green lanterns so what
what's implied is
at least that's what i'm thinking when i
watched it is that the first green
lantern that you see in the the battle
the age of heroes he gets his arm cut
off he's dead
and then the green lantern that you see
in the apocalypse world where the jl
statue is you got superman flying with
batman's head there's a green lantern
lying there
that's who's the next green lantern to
protect the earth and then he's killed
off in the future
these lanterns suck at doing their job
is what i'm saying yeah just keep dying
no lanterns we wiped them out first
no kryptonian but he'll be back
um liam koch oh thank you so much it's
really generous of you buddy yeah
um i didn't even notice that lois was
pregnant
okay that insert boy i didn't even
notice that lois was pregnant so i
watched new rockstars any explainer
video senior carrying the baby basket
into the house and hearing bruce say
congratulations
what what i didn't even catch that what
all i saw was the pregnancy
[Laughter]
that's really fun damn yeah i'm gonna
have to go back and scour for that
i saw the pregnancy test and it seemed
like okay that's there for a reason
yeah but i don't know what but i'm like
i'm assuming that we'll find out she's
pregnant
but i didn't notice the oh and he was
saying congratulations i thought that
was more like uh
you got your job at the daily planet
congratulations yeah yeah
even though when you came out and
everyone was shouting clark including me
saying
clark no and lois shows up and goes
clark no
no one's put together that you're
superman nope
not at all but you're back um
yeah bruce oh wow oh i gotta go that
that is true
yeah i was also like why are you saying
congratulations because you got the
house back
that's what i thought that's more of
what it was like you got your house back
you're back here
you got your family you're doing good
congratulations that's what i thought it
was oh that's great thanks for letting
me know that
it's probably that too you know there's
a lot to be thankful for
the big o show fan of the channel check
mine out in the comment section well
thank you big show
be sure to thank you ernie furtai of
fertile
given the uncertainty of the future of
this story making the big stream would
you mind if they continue the story via
comic book issue style
i mean it'd be cool to get that it'd be
kind of cool just to get like a graphic
novel interpretation of these movies as
well like just do your adaptation
graphic like the way how they sometimes
how they've done for like the injustice
games and do that here i think they'd be
neat
uh i personally if they if they don't
have a future in in movie or hbo max
medium
i guess that's the best we'll get yeah
it's not the same keep the fight going i
keep the fight going look where we are
now
i keep the fight going because partly
because
it's so tied to a filmmaker making a
film
yeah you know that i feel like it would
be definitely cool and i think people
would definitely be interested but i
feel like to truly follow it up it
it wouldn't be anything other than a
movie yeah absolutely yeah
all right so where are we at right now
thank you guys for everyone who's been
hitting the like button that means a
hell of a lot yeah
lois was holding the cradle holy [ __ ] i
i had
wow wow there's so much i did not know
i'm looking at your guys's chat right in
the stream right now
it's gonna be one of those movies each
viewing brings out something different
you didn't see
the superman's son becomes batman i did
hear about this crazy part of the story
whoa we got to get that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] do y'all
think bruce is the father i think
there's like some version down the r
okay that's that's i guess what i was
kind of confused on tyrone's doing a
spoiler talk too right now
damn it tyrone he knows we're live you
son of a [ __ ]
i just sent you a helpful email it just
was what you get for for going live
while omni media was live
yeah it's bound to happen sometime
balance of the universe
all right so where are we at okay all
right so we got a little bit more chats
in here
gotta refresh debt
and we could also check the stream labs
just in case getting a little bit
acquainted here yeah
did we get streamlapse how long was
superman dead
i think superman i mean it it couldn't
have been a six month roll
they could yeah they could have you know
made some lovin
nine months prior oh yeah does bruce
snag mira
no we don't have any super chats uh in
streamlabs all right cool
perfect we're way wrong youtube we're
just youtubing it
all right here we go oh yeah let's do it
we're getting up thank you guys so much
for being here if you're enjoying the
stream please hit that like button we're
just
adjusting a couple of quick things don't
worry the stream will exist
this is going to make it through labs
active too in case you guys uh want to
contribute there if you happen to be
want to or able to i'll link in the
description box
oh wow there's quite a few there's quite
a few super chats from behind on here
why did we take so long per answer all
right we got this john don't worry we
so got this we already we're already
getting answer some questions here
all right hey read my comment let's go
consider yourself red brian hernandez
rate the movie out of 10 12.
uh dark side without the mother boxes
guys ah this is cool though usually the
chat isn't going this fast bruce was the
father only in the 2015 script and not
in revisions after that
you know what golly i can't imagine that
was actually real
uh are we are we blurred right now are
we blurry oh are we lagging a little bit
i think we're lagging a little bit the
internet thinking about this sorry guys
internet's gonna lag from time to time
but it'll pick back up as it has been
yes uh so what's okay
what the funny thing about martha i'm
seeing this in the chat right now
with martha ken so martian manhunter
shows up
as martha right
martha manhunter now does martha
does this conversation what if those
conversations brought back up in the
time when they're at the kent farm
that's what i kept thinking is
is like hey thanks for coming to see me
i really needed the encouragement you
helped get me back on my feet and i
wouldn't have been able to do that
without you
yeah so thank you so much you know we'll
we'll see the other side of that in
justice league too when marcia
manhunter's like hey
i know that was a little weird but it's
the only way yeah sorry i promise i
won't do that again
so um okay i've seen that our our stream
is
slightly lagging right now it's picking
up with the quality apologize about that
guys it'll pick up it does happen real
time
it'll happen from time to time you know
how this goes but i appreciate it
i think it also might just be on some of
it's on our end
if it's nobody if there's no new ones in
there
someone's saying they sent stream
elements oh well we could open up the uh
that's why
how do we open that uh well let's you
open it john
or a sec guys just give us a second
we're getting this a little bit
readjusted
but i'll answer some questions in the
chat right now favorite part of the
movie
would happen to was probably the moment
with the actress
from uh when she gets the atm part that
was one of my favorite parts
yeah absolutely that was beautiful that
oh so we got some stream elements we
need
just that that's not adjusted uh
do it later yeah
would you guys really want amelia clark
for mira
i like the mira british version a little
better i thought the nightmare
voice was not the greatest but i will
say that
early on yeah earlier on i thought it
was better there are a lot of people who
have been
like wanting amelia clark to be uh mira
instead
and i do hope we get a justice league
too we're looking at we're adjusting a
couple things right now as we're doing
this
we are checking stream elements don't
worry i i didn't realize that there was
the wrong thing in the in the
description box there
i thought it was streamlabs it was
apparently a stream elements
yeah what's going on i'm replacing this
link for now
but are you going to get at the stream
elements yes
as long as i don't bump us off well i
don't want to bump us out of here by
logging into youtube though all right
i will get those guys don't worry let's
pull up the uh
super chats here really again really
quick maybe martian spoke to martha
before i mean how did he know her
appearance
i mean i think he concluded that clark
kent where he could you know he could
he's
he's probably got you know awareness of
krypton and all
kinds of other things too and he can
probably see through a pair of glasses
yeah that's true
ah what was that
it was a place filler noise so while we
get back sorted
sorry guys give me once i'm so i'm like
you got to give me one second while i'm
adjusting something right here
i promise we'll be fully focused in one
second
just gotta get this done it's really
important
what are you trying to do trying to
adjust this copy that
one second guys just like give you five
seconds ten seconds
john wrap for them take your shirt off
keep them entertained we're losing
people
guys we're losing dynamics as as i'm
fixing this thing joker is getting
broker with the
al roker
oh goodness martian man hunter you guys
do you want to see a solo movie from
marsha van hunter
do you like harry lennox that much
holding the fort down right now
as i'm fixing this appreciate any old
time man always always always a one out
of ten what would you rate this oh okay
i give it an eight
gotcha all right okay now that we were
kind of quiet and
and unfocused for a while there we're
getting back to focusing properly okay
people would let amber heard [ __ ] on
their bed so that's good i'm glad we
established this in the chat
i mean all right here we go here we go
all right so we got some super chats
here that we got to catch up on let me
fix this
really quick and then we're good to go
i we noticed i noticed adam right away
now ryan choi
adam man oh yeah you called him out
see like before they even said video
vasquez
that's a cool name i like it hey
apparently two godzilla clips dropped
and we gotta just stop the stream right
now
yeah we'll shoot them during the stream
edit them during the stream we're
getting close we're getting close
he has telepathy martian manhunter that
would make sense yeah
that he can read minds okay i appreciate
you all for clearing that up
that's like the number one commented
thing right now
uh where's the stream lapse it's right
there
it's eyeball there we go oh my god
that's what i couldn't figure out this
whole time
thank you guys for waiting all right
where are we at
i had it john you just [ __ ] me up man
that's what i'm here for
all right left and right there we go got
it fixed it thank god
all right so knowing sign uh gnome cyan
says
love the film love the score hated the
needle drops all the actual songs were
way too on the nose borderline cringe in
my opinion
love you fellas i don't know man i think
because there's so much of
this is zack snyder's justice league
it's like if i watch a movie that's a
film by quentin tarantino
there's gonna be things that i'm like
only quinn and tarantino would choose
this song
and that's kind of the way i felt with
zack snyder's soundtracks in this movie
was like the i thought the some i think
that one of the most complained about
ones that i've heard is actually the
aquaman one when he's like taking off
his shirt walking to the shore and i'm
like i think the song works great here
in this moment
and i know that it doesn't work for
everyone but for me
i thought in this particular case
especially because of zack snyder's
justice league
i'm like be as zack snyder as you want
and like
all these songs were like super zak
snyder yeah
you know absolutely i'd expect nothing
less at this point is what i'm trying to
say
yeah i understand people's gripe with
the zack snyder music video
as they call it as everyone seems to
call it um i
didn't it didn't bother me in this movie
partly because maybe it was just the
choice of songs like
like watchmen is a movie that has like
the most recognizable songs used and i
don't even
dislike all those cues but like that
movie has like a playlist of just
the most go-to song for whatever song
choices being presented at the time
and so this one felt less like that but
at the same time it felt very zack
snyder so i can understand
yeah if his needle drops aren't your
flavor
and they distract you then i probably i
would guess it's not going to change
here
oh man but i thought they were good they
didn't distract me because they weren't
the songs i was as familiar with
so uh yeah i think that's another
benefit too the song choices is like i i
don't know those songs as well so it's
not all along the watching
my personal taste i'm like yeah it's
kind of sounds like a new song
yeah yeah yeah yeah um joe kerr
kurt says fire walter hamada and restore
the snyder verse
yes siree i mean i guess
i guess it's the point we're at you know
like i i happen to like most of the dc
eu
i wish they could just figure out a way
to properly work together i felt like
they backed out too
soon i felt like they had they hit the
panic button
too strong after bbs yes they oh
absolutely like after bvs and they
and i i think if they just let zack
snyder even get to like a three to three
and a half hour film
even like if if we had this version but
like in a three to three and a half hour
version i think we would have stuck
around for it
it's justice league it's an epic bring
them all together movie i think we
and if it had good reviews we would have
stuck around it's that that plain and
simple
and so i just kind of wish they would um
i don't know find a way to make it work
again
but i feel like the public war is just
so out there it's
so out like like while ray fisher has
been way more direct about it
yeah zack snyder has just he said enough
to know like
he's got some feuds with warner brothers
you know he's got some [ __ ] with warner
brothers he's gotta
that he'd have to hash out before ever
working with them them specifically
again
the credit always goes to hbo max geez
that would be awkward
yeah well and i mean it makes you wonder
if maybe there's hope in the hbo corner
in the future maybe
jimmy woods thank you for your super
chat what was your thoughts on junkie xl
score
um i mean we did a whole spiel about it
earlier in the stream
pay grade unfortunately you have to go
back but i mean i think that it does a
great job
auditory wise taking you on my here's
how it's sum it up
if you're ever working out just listen
to the score from beginning to end
and i guarantee you'll feel like you've
been on an emotional journey right then
and there and i thought every scene was
complemented exceptionally well
amazonian q-tune for wonder woman
was one of the most badass things in the
world msund
thank you for the super chat hello to
canada kenneth robin
a junior so much better than justice
league
it's pretty crazy how it went from
someone who actually was like that's a
fun saturday morning cartoon
to then go and whoa
i don't like this movie now i don't love
this anymore like i
had a lot of fun when i saw that
saturday morning cartoon i always knew
snyder
cut would be better i didn't think it
would be so much better to the point
where i actually
really dislike the joss's one now i
can't watch like i watch it and i cringe
i see an image of it and i create it
it's cringy yeah yeah it's like
i
it's just like you're seeing the wrong
thing and you and you know it
intrinsically yeah it's like i don't
want any of these images in my head
this isn't right this is weird what's
going on i don't want to think about any
of this when i think about justice
league anymore
now i want to find the stream where
someone is passionately being like
why the josh version is so much better
um lucifer you have some sexy beards
xoxo thank you
i appreciate it coming from you that
means a lot uh
joker hire deborah snyder hire both
deborah and zach they're
they're packaged you gotta get them both
i wanna see what a deborah snyder
directed dc movie looks like
the game lover um thank you everyone for
the super chats by the way it really
means a lot um i love this movie but i
don't think it needed to be four hours
long but it was still worth it
you see there
look dude did we want to sit in these
[ __ ] chairs for four hours
and watch a movie like no initially we
did it like there was a
thought process too of like do we want
to sit here
in these chairs before i feel like that
would get very uncomfortable
and it kind of flew by for us
and i feel like i wouldn't have it any
other way you know like
can i see a version of this that's three
to three and a half hours
undoubtedly i i can't see a two hour
version i can't even see a two and a
half hour version
i could see a three to three and a half
hour version yes but at that point i'm
like
i might as well get the the whole buffet
yeah you know i might as well get every
item here
yeah if it's gonna be three and a half
hours might as well see it all in the
scope the director wishes to have it be
seen in
yeah i i guess i would say that that no
i don't know if any movie ever truly
needs to be four hours but this movie
feels
for the most part very natural and
breathable at four hours and it doesn't
feel or it didn't feel to me like a four
hour experience
and uh that's i guess where i would fall
on it's being too long or not like does
it need to be four hours
i suppose not but yeah i'd say it was
still worth it a plus yeah yeah
it was still i like there are some
scenes where i'm like okay sure you
could have trimmed this
like like when aquaman goes into the
water and then there's the song being
played uh
they start singing every music video
like yeah
that part of it i'm like well it
to me that's that's a big complaint
that's something i've seen on twitter
threads of people really going back and
forth about
aquaman diving into the water and then
and then them
singing and smelling the sweat or
holding the sweater close
but i'm like no i mean that to me that
communicates a sense of the culture
that communicates a sense of that as
much as this guy
claims he doesn't want to do heroic [ __ ]
he is idolized
you know i think there's a lot of
meaning and subtext
to that little moment there that i was
like no in terms of moving the plot
along
no it doesn't but it it does enhance it
for me
it does make it more rich for me do we
that's the problem with the [ __ ]
joss's thing it's all about plot plot
plot plot plot
when i'm like no you need to have time
where you slow down for character stuff
or world building or cultural things so
like that's a moment that i see a lot of
people make fun of
but for me it made it more worth it
especially whenever you cut back to this
[ __ ] village that he just seems to be
hanging out in
yeah it's like you're adding to the
mystique like to me those are moments
to indulge in the mystique and to make
that you know the sort of aura that
lives
beyond just the person who is the hero
it exemplifies that stuff sorry
no are you gonna say no it's like you
you could cut it down
but i'm not mad they didn't if that
makes sense i really appreciate everyone
who's been here this whole time man i
mean this is like it's
it's been a really rewarding live stream
um it's been fun
i really want to hit my vape to be
honest go for it
no man it's not illegal it's not weed
no it's not illegal we started the last
really craig so long
rhys lively zack snyder's justice league
is by far my favorite dc eu film my
question is what are your thoughts on
the martian manhunter cameo
um it's definitely my top we did talk
about the martial manhunter cameo quite
in depth a little bit earlier
but to sum it up i'm really satisfied
it's here and i'm hoping we get zack
sanders justice league
in the future uh part two so that way we
can see more martian manhunters that way
that ending doesn't feel
as much of a cliffhanger much of a tease
for a sequel and it will make it feel
more complete in its overall story
because i mean that's obviously what
zach's been trying to do man of steel
to justice league three and so if we can
get that whole ep
because like this movie alone feels like
a lord of the rings epic fantasy
this one solo movie but in the scope and
breath of
from man of steel to this i'm like wow
beautiful
absolutely i'm in love with it
absolutely love with it so glad this
movie is
good you imagine this no for real you
imagine this sucks
well it's good and also it seems to
be quintessentially itself i don't know
like there's something very graceful
about how it came out and
it could have very much not even been
that so like i don't know there's
something very special i think about the
circumstances of how this came
to us well the pacing the pacing works
beautifully
because it starts off slow and it slowly
ramps up the pacing slowly picks up by
the time you're in the last hour
it's moving quite quick yeah absolutely
and it gets there it earns its way there
as and it doesn't feel like we're
rushing to get to the end yeah it builds
and it builds momentum
you know over time and sund that's mr
sunday who's here in our chat right now
i appreciate that
do you always think you would have liked
his original theatrical version as much
as this one
i think it would have been skewered four
years ago
i mean that's no i don't i mean that's
kind of the way like whatever his
theatrical cut would have
been it probably would have been i mean
i don't know i'm gonna say probably
most like 99 likely would have been
better than the justice version
but he was in a position where he felt
like he had to pare it down you know
and um jeremy johns actually brought
this up it was a great point in his
non-spoiler review that
even if he did a four-hour version he
had to cut it up into two parts
two movies it still would have felt like
because of the fact that it's cut up
part one would have ultimately felt like
it's just a setup for part two yeah
oh yeah where would you have done a
proper ending for it
yeah it would have just felt like a like
like [ __ ] hunger games or that kind
of [ __ ] where you're like what the hell
is just a
setup you know so it needs to be in its
full
length for it to be the best film it has
to be like for it to be the best it
could possibly be
it has to be this length yeah like i'm
telling you like bvs ultimate edition
versus bvs theatrical
it's like wildly different experience
you know
yeah that's not even nowhere near as
long as this one
yeah well that's the thing too is like i
feel like if again if none of this would
have happened i don't think
i just can't help but think we wouldn't
have seen
this version it would not have been this
long it would have still had to
compromise in a lot of ways and so i
almost feel like
no i guess i'd split the difference and
say it might have been received better
than justice league and not as well as
this version
um but yeah i i sort of feel like the
version we got is largely and due to the
circumstances it underwent to get here
so yeah i don't think it would have been
uh
uh loved as much as this mr vaju
i tweeted an apology to zack snyder for
losing faith in his vision
and doubting him after bvs that he
completely redeemed himself
with this cut i think it's so important
and that's kind of what i've been trying
to do is
lay it out there it's like when i put
out our video the zack snyder uh
the immediate reaction review i had
people who were like i remember these
guys crapping on on zack snyder just a
few years ago
like guys i went further than that i
didn't just crap on bvs
i did a whole dedicated video
about why the save martha moment is so
stupid
and um and how they could have finally
could have talked about it
like my i just just went in on it
and not long ago i took time out of a
video out of one of our reaction videos
to talk about
why i take that all back and i went into
depth
about like i actually love that
and the ultimate edition it makes sense
why superman doesn't say something right
up front
the say martha moment is powerful like
and i i really go into like extensive
detail as to why
to show that i'm not just saying that to
say that like i can
really specify why it's that great
and i think that that's kind of happened
with a lot of people with his movies
and i'm we just happen to be one of them
is
not liking this [ __ ] at first and we
have the unfortunate part of like [ __ ]
we put out a video
without like two videos a couple years
ago and now we feel different
and fortunately we started feeling
different before snyder cut was
officially announced for hbo max
and i'm glad that that way i could
really feel exception i've always been
for the snyder cut but i feel like more
enthusiastic about it because of the
fact that
i really started to feel like i i
grasped what everyone else was grasping
about as [ __ ]
and a lot of the early it's okay to
admit it i think it's okay to be like
yeah i actually didn't i hated it at
first but eventually i started to kind
of get it and then i started to really
get it and
like i love it you know well yeah
there's also a lot that happens
especially in
in this kind of cycle that we do and
reviewing movies and stuff like that
where you know opinions change over time
for almost any movie review so
part of it is yeah leave it up because
it's a document of the truth
yeah like i was won over and in some
ways it's more rewarding to be won over
by something that you weren't initially
on board with or that you didn't
see the full scope and scale of and one
of the cool things
like it's it's a problematic aspect of
zack snyder's filmmaking across a
franchise like this because again
not everyone is going to be patient
enough to fund three giant movies but
you know
it's also been an experience where as i
see more and more and more of his vision
play out
i like it a bit more each time i love it
yeah yeah every time i love him
yeah and this was like my favorite
iteration of it culminating
you know even the theatrical cut of bvs
i watched that
hated it the second time i watched it i
liked it a little bit more third time i
watched it i'm like okay i like this
movie
well done it wasn't that i mean like two
three but the ultimate edition was like
a new movie to me
and that it is like when he by the time
batman's like
no i'll save martha [ __ ] i started
crying yeah
like damn that's like he's a hero again
yeah i love it
so yeah that's uh some good [ __ ]
um gnomes so i'm saying yeah man if you
if you got one over you don't need to
have an ego about it i hated pirates too
the first time i saw it loved it
became my favorite one eventually
[ __ ] i walked out of goddamn
hot rod and napoleon dynamite ended up
loving those movies when i watched it
again
and uh it was a suicide squad i liked
the first time i watched it and then on
re-watch i hated it
you know so opinions can change man
they're not finite
um which is great you can always trust a
reviewer on youtube who says that
we put all together way too much stock
especially in america on like picking
one stance and never
deviating from it ever we don't like uh
character growth no i'm saying no matter
the version snyder's barry allen still
has a goofy as [ __ ] running style no
hate though just silly
you know it's a little goofy he's still
getting his grip
on it though he's still you're like
there's little things about barry allen
that i
everyone's first day his there's some
things that he does that i [ __ ]
love um i love a the example of the
necessity for the suit
i like when his shoes rip off and he's
like stumbling when he's running out to
get iris like
and um and oh but when he does
when he's like prepping himself before
the battle when he does like his
meditations breathing
yeah you know getting in touch with
himself a little meditative stuff
those little details i think make go a
long way for for a viewer like myself
and making something feel more lived in
and more human
and so i feel like he's still so new to
this so while he does have a bit of a
goofy run
there's not one [ __ ] moment in here
that is anywhere near as goofy as the
[ __ ]
closing shots of justice league
like that [ __ ] is so wildly goofy and
there's
not one part in this movie actually made
me laugh at that whereas in
justice version it was it was like why
is he running like that this is so goofy
yeah i was looking to just set him up in
front of a green screen or like run
you know it was a thing that i kept
expecting to look silly at some point
throughout
zack snyder's justice league and never
fully got there like there are elements
of yeah the floaty kind of
posture that he does but yeah nowhere
near as much as in justice league
so it was a it was a lot better here
than ever before i would say
pig me monkey i cried multiple times
during this i had very low expectations
but i was blown away awesome hope you
remember me by the way you made me a
couple shout outs to me long ago you all
are great we do remember you pygmy
hey good to see you got a name like that
thank you so much for your super chat
yeah i was moved to tears quite a bit
i'll use this time to talk about a
moment that i felt a little bit
underwhelmed by um
it was one of my nitpicky moments okay
and i know this has happened when we
first watch it together and it happened
the second time i watched this too was
when silas stone dies silas stone dies
and so i started like getting a little
misty-eyed like
this [ __ ] died on this [ __ ] cyborg
just can't catch a goddamn break
he's a [ __ ] cyborg now he lost his
mommy
he lost his whole future now his dad
dies right before him
i started getting misty-eyed there's
something about the way the
moments following it that play out that
feel like there's a lack of emphasis on
the fact that he just lost his father
that's fair it kind of moves a little
quick into into
cyborg being like let's go get this guy
i know why my dad died
even like bruce shows up and i feel like
bruce
would have a little bit of compassion
for him in this moment
absolutely other than just the line of
like uh your this that's your father
died for a reason
like it was kind of just quick and about
like let's get on back on the mission
and i get there in time crunch
i get the mother box was just taken i
get they got a lot working against them
and it's a matter of time crunch
and while you can talk and while you do
get a scene later where
um aquaman is talking with barry and
saying
you know um we're about to have this guy
do this mission who just lost his father
and it's a great moment for aquaman
actually the way he did that has that
scene
where he's like i never said i didn't
care there's something about the moments
and what
like right after silas died to them
figuring out why silas
let himself die that felt like there was
a there should have been a little bit of
a heavier beat i felt
yeah um like whoa he just lost his dad
and i feel like
like the justice league batman they're
all kind of moving past us
a little quick right now yeah i mean
it's it's one of those movie conundrums
i think where it's like okay how do we
throw a scene in the midst of all the
action but yeah i i
i would have certainly been pleased to
see
more of that cyborg emotionals yeah you
know
by the way i'm loving all the comments
that are going on in this chat right now
it's making me very happy like i've
been paying attention to it all oh yeah
keeping an eye out that's why
that's where a lot of my random tidbits
of conversation
in the middle of a super chat come from
it's from you guys be in the chat
appreciate that
um so yeah but but to say at least i did
cry multiple times too
oh yeah i i definitely cried it's a tear
jerker
zack snyder's tear jerker zack snyder's
it's okay to cry if you're a man movie
it's one of those
happy tears to man yeah tears of triumph
[ __ ] here's the thing
yeah the guy feeling some kind of
confidence in himself for the first some
pride for the first time
in this forum i might be able to enjoy
this i might not have to be
like just imprisoned in a life of misery
i can do something no one can do yeah
except superman obviously sarah campbell
appreciate you sarah how you doing sarah
thanks for replying to me on patreon
recently sarah
sarah i haven't seen the movie
i appreciate it awesome spoilers i
haven't seen the movie but i got
really invested what happened after with
amanda maude who played the waitress
uh the the asian mother with the the atm
machine
so heart warping to see people excited
her scene was in the movie so sweet
that's the effectiveness of of great
visual storytelling absolutely that's
why you need zack snyder to be able to
embrace his slow-mo i
i really think i didn't even fully
comprehend
some of the usage of his slow-mo until
this movie
like when you do have wonder woman
countdown on 10 on the bomb and she's
figuring all this [ __ ] out about how to
[ __ ]
knock out all these people in 10 seconds
or cyborg
having to think in his head really quick
when he's playing football to get
to you know that's a yeah that's a great
little details like capture the fury of
them in their slow-mo
and their thought pro like you know it's
it's a little physical moment they're
not telling you but yeah you're watching
like how they assess
the scene before they do the cool super
[ __ ] yeah in real life human beings are
like having thoughts move at a mile a
minute you know like super quick
and we slow it down you're like you can
see there's so much going on in the
thought process
and plus it just looks [ __ ] cool
yeah i mean it is a satisfying
i don't know i mean i i wonder if
somebody out there has made just a super
cut of all of them because i got to feel
like you know if you remove them from
the context of the films
even people who are haters on them
probably got to admit they're
they're effective little audio visual
tone pieces you know
you know i am so grateful for this live
stream like
the fact that we have been live for
almost two hours and we have had
a consistent 1.3 to 1.4k viewers
this whole time really warms my heart
and i appreciate because we have really
taken our time with deep diving into
this and i feel like we got so much more
left in us oh yeah
and just to give you guys an example of
how behind we are on super chats
this is our bar that we're dealing with
here
so we got we're only like we got the
titanic scroller freshness yet
we got the tiny scroll and i really like
i sincerely appreciate that and i
appreciate everyone who's been here this
whole time because
like this like this movie has meant a
lot and it's been such a journey
and so to have you guys be like a
participant in this journey with us has
been like
amazing um thank you for sharing it
thank you so much like this has meant a
lot
and uh yeah like [ __ ]
it's like this movie's been so long in
development just to see
just you know what's been great too
about the fact that it's four hours long
because of the fact that it's four hours
long it's not something that people can
just watch in a day and only go trending
for a day
yeah this is something that like the day
before it premiered at midnight it went
trending
and it's trending all day thursday
trending on friday it's been trending
today
and it's so cool to see how like because
it's four hours not everyone can finish
it or watch it
until like friday or saturday so it's
just gonna keep trending for a while
like what a what a beautiful moment in
cinematic time like this to me
is the ultimate game changer for
streaming services
because like what doors does it open up
to like wow a four-hour
movie is getting so many people watching
this and it's been trending this is like
such an event well that's the thing is
you might see
like i know a lot of people are talking
about that like oh if they had to worry
about theatrical this would not have
been four hours
and part of me wonders if i mean they
can't all be this
scale of like hundreds upon hundreds
upon hundreds of millions of dollars to
make but
i wonder if we will start seeing bigger
wider
longer movie format things come to
streaming where they don't have to worry
about things like how many times we can
play this in our theater in a day to
make the money back
right you know because part of the
reason of restricting the time is so
they can play it more times
so i i guess i don't expect the movie to
set a precedent but at the same time i
could imagine
some visions being a lot more accessible
given the success of this
right it's interesting it's quite
interesting we're able to find the
stream elements one
yeah we can log in i i don't think it'll
destroy this stream to do so
all right do your thing john ricky luke
cage jones
the differences in theatrical cut and
the snyder cut is the easiest way to
show and explain how racism
at your job works ricky luke kate jones
you know i'm not sure i would agree with
that i think they only cut out the asian
and black people
so
no they they definitely i mean i don't
know if it's exactly a a confirmation of
how racism works but
when you do watch it and you're like
they did cut out like the asian and
black people and this you can't help but
kind of go
i think there was there there might have
been
it's certainly it kind of seems
pretty apparent that they cut out asian
and black people yeah
this is there's no two ways about that
that's hinky like that's
strange because again it excises like so
much of the personality the character
like the heart
of the it hurts the movie to remove a
lot of that stuff so it seems like they
wanted to for some reason yeah and that
is baffling to me absolutely
uh yeah hashtag racism sucks
okay we know some people contribute to
our stream elements from the earlier
stream so we're going to log into here
right now
and if we lose the stream i'm sorry but
we don't think
theoretically we will lose this stream
set up here as
you know you got to log in with the same
account that you're using two streams so
i think it'll work
i think it'll be i think it'll be let's
see if we're still
it'll be fine uh we're just trying to
access the stream elements here of
course has like a million
uh uh uh walls as long as we don't go
live on stream elements we'll be a-okay
right
yeah i think we should be fine
oh wow we got quite a bit yeah
cool breaking them in okay all right we
gotta we gotta make sure we catch up on
these two okay so if we click them
individually that's how we
all right cool so we're gonna catch up
on some stream elements here
which have a much more wider variety of
questions as well and of course go
through here
but yeah mixing up the conversation
really quick yeah
john are committed to honoring everybody
everyone who contribute
if you contribute it if you're here if
you're in the room uh bradley
first just click it just click it uh
click the que
oh no yeah you said just click click the
question yeah go go click the question
hold on john okay fix this john we're
losing viewers by the way
everyone's everyone hates me all right
1 to 13 of 13. perfect all right here we
go
hey guys all right this is looking a
little small
but not for long here we go hey guys if
no one's asked yet what'd you think
thank you bradley also by the way great
question
of the joker scene do you think jared
leto could be on the road
to redemption much love to you both do i
think jared leto could be on the road to
redemption
yes i think if you get a one look
he hasn't won over everyone all right it
wasn't long enough and it wasn't enough
variety
to make people to make everyone get on
board i know some people who really are
like nah i still don't like it
and there are some people who are very
much more on board for what he has to do
or what he can do
abs absolutely i think what we really
need
is to hate do we need i think we do we
need the haircut because
there's been so much talk about like you
guys have no idea how good joker is in
that
you guys have no clue what jared leto
did
so i think what we really need is like
is it the road to
yeah i think the road has begun if
i mean the success of the snyder cut
certainly makes the air cut be a reality
that you could entertain for yourself
like i mean he went trending
yeah he went trending again i was i was
holding my breath because i was like
okay if the snyder cut drops and it's
lukewarm or it's okay or it's not that
great
no haircut but like this is seems like
the best
possible outcome is the movie dropped
the fans who wanted it love it but also
people who didn't want it are also being
like damn this is i'm actually surprised
by how much i like this oh are we
lagging it's lagging here although when
we've asked in the past people have
responded being like it's fine over here
so i think it's mostly
this is doing like a real time playback
for us and it's also probably keeping it
low quality
systems and blah blah but yes if we are
lagging it
just horribly let us know see like in
the chat that i've seen some people who
have been saying
jared leto should be getting recast and
there's some people who love what
geraldo did
i really liked what he did i mean he was
eerie he was unsettling to me
he was off-putting in a way that's not
like i don't want to watch this
character it was like off-putting in a
way we're like
this guy's creepy you know like my point
with that though is it's still like you
ask people about heath ledger it's like
clearly the majority
love heath ledger yeah you asked me
about walking phoenix
clearly the majority love walking
phoenix i feel like
he has won a lot more people over
i don't think he has won enough people
over yet
that's fair and i mean jared tink and i
mean jared leto
i guess now in the space that he
occupies in the public eye
i feel like has more ground to make up
it's not it's not just that people
don't like the suicide squad theatrical
cuts joker it's also that jared leto is
a bit of a meme
in and of himself and is a personality
that not everybody
cares for and so like that's that's
something that i feel like they might
have to work past but i feel like if we
got an air cut and people saw that and
it is true that his joker performance is
something special i feel like that'll
that'll be the solution there yeah i
mean see like the more i'm seeing here
uh the more i'm seeing here the more i'm
like yeah there are people here
life of nate we gave you we gave you
several responses buddy
and if you've got one that we haven't
got to yet just hold on we're getting
everything because we're behind
on questions we got a lot of questions
to get to boy we take time to answer
the people's questions everybody the
people's ques the people's fist
craig stratton hey three hours ago oh
boy
barry saved the world by remember we got
late to open up this page
barry saved the world by reversing time
that was peak awesomeness
absolutely 100 that is actually the most
um that is the most talked about i was i
felt like
with the what the stream would tell us
is what are the biggest takeaways
easily we've taken a lot of questions
today yeah in the last two hours
easily barry is the most talked about
yeah which i'm actually surprised by
sequins
alone and i i don't i think the last
thing people were expecting to really
talk about was
barry allen being like him having the
most hiding sequence and
the most focused on season it is oh it's
i'm still thinking i like every time it
crosses my mind i'm like i just want to
watch it again
you know mr vaiju do you think mephisto
killed lois lane in the future nightmare
good to see you guys back i hope so he
did
that'd be the greatest crossover it was
ralph's owners look they didn't put
mephisto in one division so i did
i am giving every fan what they want i
could do whatever i want
if they're not you're still getting what
you want i'm still getting mephisto in
there
yes i think it is good i heard they're
on one of the uh the engravings on the
name when flash is fighting with
superman that one of the names is ben
parker
i don't know if that was some fake ass
tweet or if that's
accurate you know or somebody made up a
random name and then went gosh
eric eric long time
loyalist here long time no see totally
think the zack snyder wonder woman is so
much better than paddy's
wow never thought i'd be i'd ever say
that was going to ask you about this but
you were literally answering as i typed
how funny
it was really honey earlier but when i
leading up to the snyder cut i watched
the films in order man of steel bvs
ultimate edition
and wonder woman the night before
watching zack snyder's justice league
i wanted the full experience and to me
i personally would have to agree with
this i'm not just saying it like her
portrayal of like badass amazonian
warrior like i love her in that first
wonder woman movie
i [ __ ] love her she's amazing
but her portrayal here is
just like so
lethal so godlike just
the fact that she shows up to that
highest with no sword and it's just like
fisting everything fisting out everyone
she's just putting her fists on
all their asses like man zack snyder
with the lasso around her rectal exams
in this movie
yeah i feel weird saying it but but this
was my favorite wonder woman appearance
because she
she does feel like the warrior and also
in the quiet moments i really felt the
history of like
especially yeah and if you remove
the context of seeing wonder woman 1984
not even to slight that movie
but if you remove that from your mind
you're like damn i do
feel the underneath subtext of her
character this person who has been here
for a long time who has been kind of
laying low
and who is yeah like i could feel just
all of that descent
in her presence and then when she would
fight it was like a different caliber it
seemed like yeah she was
it's the most amazon she's felt to me
like a true
amazon warrior is here and the music
embellishments and the interpolations on
her theme they did with adding the
vocalizations and stuff
and you know even by association
with the themyscira sequence early on in
the film
it really gave wonder woman an
extra-late layer of presence that i was
not expecting
and i was sitting here feeling kind of
funny i was like damn
even though i yeah like wonder woman is
at the top toward the top of my dc eu
ranking i'm like this is probably my
favorite wonder woman hands down
you know i do i do think that she and
like the way she interacts with bruce
like
especially like remember this scene when
they hold they had to touch the hand
they touched that what happened there we
did it with like
i don't need the sequel i haven't heard
anything about like
what if bruce and diane are supposed to
hook up but when they do it's like
i love their the way they handle the
comedy there justice league too is a
romantic comedy
the comedy here is even better than than
josh sweden's
like joss whedon i thought the lasso
scene was funny as [ __ ] when aquaman
sitting on it that's
funny that's funny too it's really funny
but overall i think the comedy is
handled better here
yeah which is the other one that's the
funny thing and i think that's what's
really
brought me toward the love of this movie
is uh that it's like i was expecting a
lot of stuff and i was expecting a
better experience overall but what i
wasn't expecting
this movie to have so much and and so
satisfying for me
was heart and humor like and warmth
brought on by those things because i was
like yeah i don't associate zack snyder
with humor but hey this
this is appropriately funny for what it
is and it's in every character's voice
who's being funny at the time
it's great yeah so phleb doran thank you
eric horseman
phleb doran thank you flev another one
of our loyal patrons has a couple of
ones here hi guys man like how many
people are here in the stream still
two hours like almost two hours combined
with the fail first stream
like over 1200 like that's really great
for us honestly so thank you guys
that means a lot to have you guys here
10 times what we normally
have literally like wow so i really
appreciate that like
we haven't gone live in forever so thank
you um
hope you guys are enjoying the stream
flev doran hi guys
just finished the film two hours ago
definitely the superior cut
an actual enjoyable film with the depth
of characters wonder woman is the best
it's crazy how like two wonder womans
back to back uh
everything made sense but sam will not
get to see the continuation
at least not anytime soon key word in
the last
part of your secret chat there don't
know if i can stay up for the stream if
it restarts again hashtag restart the
stream hell yeah we did
just want to say how much wb left out of
the og release all that character built
dark side martian they could have fit
all that in theatrical cut why wb
y they don't like money or or people
liking their movies
also what are your favorite low-key
moments mine is the scene when martian
comes at bruce's house and how
nonchalant bruce was about a green
alien play with it i mean we talked
about that earlier
um you know what my favorite low-key
moment was
it there's two there's it's very they're
two very subtly played scenes
um and it's actually surprisingly easy
for me to answer this it's when they're
digging up superman's grave yeah
when that starts and that whole
interaction there
between a barry and cyborg if there's
one thing that i felt was
actually missing out of a four-hour
movie for me
if there's one thing i felt was missing
and that's just because i loved this
beat so much
was when flash um
when flash looks at clark's grave and
says
he was my hero like wow that's yeah
powerful that's beautiful and then you
go to this conversation
with um the femiskirans
and and atlanteans amazonians the
mosquitoes
the amazonians and atlanteans uh
and like you have aquaman and wonder
woman talking by the van with each other
and them talking about the history of
where they come from and the phrase that
connects them
yes like that scene i really love and i
really love
too when uh scene i brought up earlier
when when flash
is talking with aquaman and aquaman's
like we're gonna have cyborg do this
mission after his dad just died i forget
the exact dialogue but yeah
but flash looks at him and says i don't
think he'd care
and then aquaman says i didn't say that
ah
look at this like like [ __ ] aquaman's
performance in this
is it performance they're all so good in
here like
and the the quiet like there's it feels
like a
out of anyone's performance that feels
wildly different
for some reason it's aquaman's it does
it really does because he feels
necessary he plays it so
brooding and straightforward and like
um he he embodies that role so well of
like
the guy who doesn't give a [ __ ] but you
know underneath he really gives a major
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah and he's not too much of
a cartoon character
anything like there's a there's a quiet
gravity it's not the most
fleshed out yeah like cyborgs and barry
allen's like those are the most fleshed
out
yeah wonder woman's does feel different
but it's more of a
direc a better reinterpretation whereas
aquaman i'm like oh you like feel like a
different dude to me in this movie you
know yeah 100
i mean you you took the best ones i'll
i'll throw in uh uh
barry and his dad like i really like
those scenes without really
and especially by the end like that was
one where you know i mean we've seen
again
we know that that's part of barry's
story but we've seen this scene this
type of
you know uh progression a lot but by the
end especially when he's like you know
that's my son he's got the job oh that
brought me to
that was so touching to me like i yeah i
really loved
him and his dad together it's so weird
to feel like we're two hours into a
stream
and there's still so much more to unpack
i know
it's like we only just got to jason
mojoa's performance
which again like yeah all over the place
him across the movie like
i really liked what what he did because
again like it's a character that
you can then see like yeah he's totally
the kind of guy who could be like
badass my man yeah but at the same time
he did have just like this
holy different presence that was like
quiet but strong yeah and i really loved
it i personally thought
it's weird you know i'm not just saying
it out of like rose-colored glasses
this is my favorite wonder woman
portrayal
maybe not my it's not my favorite wonder
woman journey but it's my favorite
portrayal from gal gadot
yeah and for aquaman i liked him more
here than i did in his solo movie
he was just more gripping yeah 100 like
like he had way more
presence and like even in his quiet
moments i was engrossed by him
and i was feeling a character and again
it was it's weird to talk about these
movies in terms of like i could feel
what the actor's homework was
underneath but everyone gave me that in
this movie like everyone even when they
like that's why sweden relies on quippy
dialogue he does
yeah whereas zack snyder can capture a
an actor's performance
with just the eyes and the visuals and
the body language which is what
a lot of actors have to rely on yeah a
lot of actors have these performances
where people don't know what they're
talking about they just opt in
a lot of a lot of actors have these
performances
where they do all this history and
homework and know all the characters
background and they got to bring it all
into a performance
that and we're probably not going to
touch on 99 of what the homework is that
they did yeah there's gonna be almost no
dialogue and i thought jason momoa
really brought that yeah all right here
we go
he should like he truly felt like he was
a warrior who could become the king but
wasn't there yet
you know bradley bledsoe thank you
bradley hey congratulations again
for your uh daughter hey guys since you
answered the joker question the first
stream what did you think of the usage
of hallelujah in the end it could not
stop crime personally lol
what i find great about that is you know
eric voss from new rock stars did a
great breakdown of the first trailer for
this movie which had
like how the the reflection of uh
of uh the the lyrics matching with the
visuals but this is also autumn's
favorite song his daughter who passed
away it's her favorite song
so you cannot end this movie without the
cr without the credits having that song
of hallelujah and i think it was the
same person who performed that song at
her funeral
yeah there's a particular rendition i
guess that was her favorite
absolutely beautiful and yeah and it's
funny because that is such a loaded
it's it's a loaded song to needle drop
in a movie because it is such a distinct
such a well beloved such a frequently
covered
song that this i mean this it's like
it's in watchmen during like a sexy
you know whereas this felt like
especially for zack snyder the most
true and the most beautiful use of it a
because it is
a lesser-known rendition and b because
it does
come as this sort of coda to the
experience to sort of remind you who
this is all
dedicated to so you know and also
bringing it back really quick
um to the to the thing about
performances i want to bring it back to
i think why they might give the best
performances
and why they might be the better
portrayals of
like even though wonder woman's had her
solo movie even though aquaman's had a
solo movie why
we might personally love these
portrayals a little bit more
is because zack snyder's the one who
cast them
he had purpose he there was reason
behind like no
i want you're you don't want me to cast
this person
but trust me i want this person and only
zack snyder
like zach sander mainly i think was the
one who was able to see what they could
do
yeah that others prob that studio people
probably weren't able to do and i think
that's why i like
getting these performances of aquaman
and wondering who have had their own
solo movies
they might shine in a different light
here because of the fact that zack
snyder was the one who found them
original because you're finally seeing
what the vision
was through the guy who selected
everybody that's a great point i didn't
thought of that yeah
snyder could make a cool extra movie i'm
actually wearing the daredevil hat
because he said he i think he can make a
great daredevil movie
oh 100 yeah eric horseman this is for
all the dead horses
oh dude those poor poor poor
oh amazon horses that was
and human horses there's a lot of horses
a lot of dead horses in that scene
but not batman's horse where's batman's
horse that's we didn't get the bat horse
back
i loved watching the [ __ ] um
that amazonian fight man that the
themscure fight
oh like this is so much better it was
just like
it's so much better he captures those
amazon
the amazonians in a way that are so
they feel like greek goddesses or
something you know they feel like
like warrior goddesses all of them
they're like these brutal machines
and the the style the uh the sleekness
they felt like
you know what they were they felt like
the female equivalent version of the 300
you know 100 percent that's what they
felt like 300 yeah because the thing is
i mean you know with the cause like
they're sexy but they're not like sexy
in the ugly eye kind of way
of like ooh half naked chicks it's like
they're sexy and the fact that they are
full on warrior women
yeah and there's some things they can
[ __ ] me up yeah yeah
yeah no no i think that is an important
thing because you know and
and it could have easily been oogly yeah
no it could like
it's tricky because yeah you would have
costumes
where you find yourself going what is
the practical why would you fight in
this
you know and and this movie avoids that
and i feel like especially i mean you
look back at justice league and it's
like a you have less
bone crunching less blood it's less
harsh action
but also if i'm not mistaken like the
approach to the depiction of the
amazon's a bit different
costuming's a bit different yeah and
yeah this really felt
like and i and we pointed this out
during the reaction like i loved that a
lot of these actresses they got
were buff had full-on abs full-on like
jacked arms like like really looked like
a culture
for whom being built like a brick [ __ ]
house and being able to handle
business whether in formation or on your
own is
key like and and yeah that came out so
much
like in in wonder woman you get the
society and you get the flavors of who
these people are and what their society
is and you get the more sort of
day-to-day flavor of that
but this one really solidified yeah this
is a tribe of
warriors a tribe you know and yeah you
really do feel like they could
demolish you bringing it back to the
dead horses part though
yes yeah let's beat the dead horse
mistakes were so
felt because she does whatever she can
to get the mother box out of wherever
the mother box is being stored right
where the parademons appear in
steppenwolf
they do the collapsing the sacrifice of
these people it falls into the water
all that for nothing yeah
that's a great way to establish your
villain as this real
threat yeah the sacrifice of your people
it collapses into the water and then
they all just come right the [ __ ] up and
they're like that ain't stopping us and
then it turns into this game of like
catch the mother box you know hot potato
yeah it's hot potato with the mother box
and
and like the choreography of this hot
mom so well
done yeah the choreography of dead
horses along the way unfortunately
well and that's the other thing too is
like that i mean rest in peace but that
also makes the action and the war
feel that much more heavy and grim is
when you got like horses being leveled
and like
what that that that is a low-key moment
when that one warrior is trapped
underneath the horse like that's real
that's a real situation for some people
you know it's heartbreaking i'm like i
cared about people i'm like i don't even
know who this woman is
but you can but you can feel how much
they care and how much exertion is
coming out so yeah it's like
a bunch of these amazons we've never
seen i'm like no please you got this
please don't die
you know yeah and that's a
testament to the direction overall is
when you care about ensemble bit players
like that too
you know jacob thank you jacob what
scene's moments gave you
chills there were quite a few the hot
dog i don't remember that in justice
league i was so happy with this cut much
improved over the first iteration
the the scene that really gave me chills
which should give people chills is
when two moments one when i touched on
earlier is when
um they go into the tunnel for the first
time once the the just
after talking with commissioner gordon
they all start hopping into frame and
it's like they're slowly walking into
the action scene
yeah you know like that is a chilling
moment to me with the music playing
but when you do get the hero shot when
they put the bat tank and the
slow motion shot when batman's taking on
all these pair of demons like he's got
the [ __ ] bat tank in uh
and reverse just shh and then turns
around and then they all show they are
they start [ __ ] helping and
the hero shot of them in the air it's an
unexpected moment for the hero shot yeah
it's unexpected where most of the time
you can kind of see that coming
it feels like kind of pushed in there it
was one of the most
earned hero shots i'd ever seen and it's
a visual way of showing
the justice league has united yeah like
they've been united they've been working
together but this is the first moment
in the whole movie where no one's had to
communicate
yeah but they know how to read each
other and they're working together and
helping each other out
so that hero shot is [ __ ] i'm getting
chills in my nipples right now
just talking about that moment and why
that moment works so well it is a
[ __ ] well-earned ass moment
this isn't obvious necessarily but for
whatever reason i was very much
enthralled it was it was it was one of
the few times during the movie where i
checked sort of someone grabbed their
pants watching this movie yeah
that's you know we said that in a video
someone had to comment if they crap
their pants so good
but um the aquaman entrance when they're
in the
tu when the gotham harbor is draining it
was one of the few moments i thought
back to
justice league and i was like oh that's
right he's not with them and he's gonna
show up
and even in the midst of me having that
thought just the way the moment played
out was so much
better and came with a much greater
sense of catharsis
because aquaman truly is like if he
didn't show up
and stop that barrage of water from from
overtaking them
they wouldn't have got out of there at
least you know or things would have
gotten
a lot worse and more complicated and
weirdly that
that gave me the chills aside from
moments that we've already discussed
heavily
uh because i was like that's an entrance
for aquaman now like hell yeah like now
and he's joining in with the team and
all that
what i can't really remember is when
aquaman does show up
he's kind of like he's you have to like
pay close attention and then suddenly
you see him he's like just standing in
the water
yeah he's kind of like appearing like an
apparition or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that's showing just how
much control he has over surfing the
waves
yeah it's like he's not overtaken by the
momentum yeah yeah i thought that was
such a great way to do it with the music
cues as well
no surprise one thing we haven't really
talked about in two hours
that no one has brought up with us is
dark side
we haven't
one it's funny because i would have
maybe even expected some people to be
like
not enough dark side they totally teased
and it was a total bust but like i i
thought even
his presence is the perfect amount to me
i don't
jacob i don't mean to hold up the stream
of back to pregnancy test i've watched
dozens of reactions reviews and people
mentioned the test but never talk about
this if you look closely she grabs the
test and goes to the bathroom
maybe implying pregnancy i think just
cutting the test implies pregnancy
uh yeah i mean i think that and then
another pregnancy one for you guys if
you got your hbo max
oh wow that's the best frame in my
opinion the baby basket she's been
martha on the steps i mean it's been
pointed out
you're not the first one in this i've
seen other people in the stream going
back and forth talking about it so
apparently lois is most certainly
pregnant
yes babies are coming i think you're 100
right jacob trust me i think you're
validated i know we've touched on this
quite a bit
but i believe you're valid this is all
just a lead up to superman and lois
um yeah there are two kids ace cash man
what a cool name yeah
i'd hate joss whedon too if i went from
essentially being the main character to
being a background character with not
much to do
referencing ray fisher that's what i
mean earlier in the stream when i was
like
he's look you cut out you cut out even
if joss reading was let's say jospin was
a really nice guy
and then you watch the movie you're like
dude you cut out all my [ __ ]
like all my [ __ ] what gives dude makes
me a character
yeah that makes anyone care that i'm
here it's like 20 minutes
like dude why would you do this you
couldn't have exercised a different 20
minutes two man 100
there with you and then uh i think we're
we're caught up here on the caught up on
the stream elements caught up on the
stream
oh hell yeah look at us catching we are
killing the g-a-m-e
you know i want to touch on one thing
about darkseid really quick if you guys
don't mind
talking about darkseid uh oh sorry
talking about darkseid here um
something that i've seen a few
criticisms brought up about darkseid
because i thought he was
i thought he was great yes he's more for
sequel setup but he has such a presence
and
does so much to inform steppenwolf's
character as well yeah and the threat of
the mother boxes and all that jazz
so i don't like as much as like his
story will feel complete if we are able
to successfully get
zack snyder's justice league two and
three i
don't i don't agree with this
there's when they say that the first
time you see dark side he gets
beaten right like he gets hit in the
shoulder
it took a lot of people to take him down
first off all the armies
took the age of [ __ ] heroes it took
or took atlanteans amazonians
lantern men all united together to take
him down
so i don't think it's as simple as some
people have been like i think it kind of
undercuts the character if he's taken
down
the first time you see him like no
you're actually showing just how much it
takes to take this guy
down and it's a younger version and one
where he's already been conquering and
that's the whole point of making the
dark side threat feel more personal
because he lost on earth and now earth
has the anti-life equation
and so the fact that he has his rage
within him he's gonna want to get his
revenge
against the people the one earth the one
world that took him down
so there is this criticism about i think
it undercuts his character i'm like no
it doesn't at all i think actually it
heightens it especially if we are able
to get
two and three he's gonna be pissed it's
gonna be personal for him to be here
yeah
yeah i mean because now he's also gonna
be pissed that he has to get his hands
dirty he's like yeah
[ __ ] the guy he sent to get it done
who he didn't even think would get it
done didn't get done
[ __ ] now i gotta do this myself you know
um
all right so we got a couple of
streamlabs super chats here thank you
guys thank you guys
cinema gorilla how's it going bud john
do you want to adjust the framing of
this a tad bit
there's just so much more to unpack when
the flash said
uh the life of justice chose me i
felt that thank you kings for the
streams all week especially the video of
actor amanda maud's story finding out
she's in the movie
comrade cyborg is real redistributing
the wealth thank you conrad cyborg
please start that please go like i want
a a c on marxist memes a
comrade cyborg just please dude
when flash said the line of justice
chose me i felt that absolutely
and amanda maud what makes me happy is
just
what amanda amanda ma for those who are
just hopping in just a little fresher
is that she is the woman at the atm who
cyborg helps get a hundred thousand
dollars
she did not know if her scene was in the
movie or not and she couldn't access the
film when it premiered
and joss whedon didn't text her and joss
whedon didn't text her back and joss
whedon said
you're asian you're out so
walter hamada sent it down the line
now that my name is so public this is
all the room we have um
so her performance um i'm glad her scene
has been landing but
like to see the how much she's been
embraced on twitter
and she actually retweeted our video as
well like that to me
i wanted i like you know you do a lot of
these videos and once in a while you
might get recognized you see
zack snyder knows who tyrone magnus is
and got recognized and that's [ __ ]
fantastic
and sometimes we're recognized by
filmmakers and that's great
but was something so personal about this
like literally when john walked in he
didn't even know about that he didn't
know about the story of of amanda mod
until i said we're going to film this
and like that was a story that really
meant a lot to me and
and i felt that it's important that
people know about it and uh the fact
that she
now knows about this so and she
retweeted our video too and i was like
so happy
that she discovered it you know it's
just another it's weird it's like it's a
weird like she's not zack snyder but
for some reason it means just as much
that she saw but
yeah i mean it's somebody whose life was
touched by this and and who
like it was just so moving to see so
many even just fans jump and be like yes
the scenes there is one of the best
scenes in the movie like we're so glad
they put it back like
and it speaks to i think you know
there's a lot
of talk about fandom but yeah it speaks
to the best of this and i love that this
movie weirdly
in the circumstances having to face so
much adversity
has brought a bunch of little side
stories that are so beautiful and
heartwarming out of
it you know so i feel like this zack
snyder's justice league was a net
positive for humanity
a thousand million percent yeah um
thank you guys so much for being here um
dude that's what i'm saying it's like a
lot of people didn't
even cover it like it's weird in the
chat right now looking looking around
it's like we're the only people who
cover
that more people would have covered it
so it's like especially this is like
especially good calling
on your that's all right oh we got the
one video no one's talking about it
and it did pretty well yeah
we could try to explain the ending or
moment we could talk about this one
little tweet that i saw
it's moments like that boys make them
special just make it truly special
net thank you nat um
if the snyder versus restored would you
want shazam included
[ __ ] yeah yeah i think he would really
mix it up
i want to see what zack snyder's shazam
is like
zakaverse zachary levi and zack snyder
yes oh that would be great i would love
to see shazam you got to get shazam in
there
especially with the age of the gods
coming in yeah man well introduce new
gods and stuff you gotta get shazam in
there
yeah and i mean superman went to school
with billy and freddie and i will say
too i think i think dwayne johnson sees
the potential
in getting black adam to be with zack
snyder because oh he's got dwayne
johnson put out
uh like he he showed the support for uh
zack snyder
so i think that he wants to he wants to
find a way to get it
like clearly it's not see here's the
thing here's the thing about the snyder
verse whether or not
you like the snyder verse or not but i
think the one thing you
people can agree on there is way
more of a passionate fan base
for zack snyder's films than there are
any of the other dc films like zack
snyder the snyder verse has a passionate
base yes or the other ones you're like
let's see if this one's good or not yeah
you know and if it is
people people might cool aquaman made a
billion dollars
no fan of like the fan base for that
aquaman movie is nowhere near as
passionate
like not one of these movies of zack
snyder's made over a billion dollars
and yet even though aquaman's made a
billion the fan base is a lot more
passionate for snyder verse than they
are for
which he had a helping hand didn't you
know obviously yeah
yeah don't know so i think yeah i feel
like they want it don't know if this was
asked but do you think
that ryan reynolds would come back yeah
i mean he was down i think he would be
down to come back for like a fun cameo
or an appearance i don't think he'd be
down to
like yeah i'll take up hal jordan again
yeah and i don't know if
if anybody would want to do that just
because it would be a meme it would be
distracting
i feel like it would be seriously either
yeah yeah it's like i wonder if it would
be anything more than a joke or
distracting just because of how much
he's embraced
how much other movies have literally
commented on green lantern all that
stuff
zach was talking with him about bringing
him back and ryan rounds was down to
like make an appearance in it
hey man but i'm sure zack snyder has a
means of doing it i wouldn't have
considered so you know
sure i'd be game if they announced it
i'd be like sure let's see what that
looks like zack center's a great guy
oh wait actually he's my best friend we
do have one more in here to do from ace
to cash man
ace i think people mad at darkseid
losing are grossly missing the fact that
it required
literal greek gods yeah exactly that's
exactly what i'm trying to say yeah
everybody required the [ __ ] world to
take him down
and the armies of men elves and dwarves
all had to come together
and and also like you you have the line
of
martian manhunter at the end when he's
talking about bruce wayne
see i feel like everything's thought out
that's the whole
point of this movie yeah like 99 of
things are
fully thought out yeah martian manhunter
at the end of the movie says i never
thought i'd see the day
again when the age of heroes would come
together yeah yeah that's the whole
point
is that in order to take down someone
like a steppenwolf or a dark side you
need the age of heroes
and not even this justice league group
equates to the level of strength
that the age of heroes was in that
battle where we saw darkseid get taken
down yeah but in darkseid
then that didn't even have the omega
beam blast nope well and the other thing
too
i i keep sitting here thinking is
technically dark side didn't lose
steppenwolf lost
and everyone on dark side side of the
boom tube was like
this guy's going to [ __ ] this up oh no
no i'm saying dark side losing when he
first gets in the first
battle oh oh yeah but yeah yeah no
you're right yeah
because even yeah cause it's the whole
point it's like it was a it was an
unprecedented moment where everyone came
together and that was the only way to
make it happen and it hasn't happened
since
get clean what does it matter
people have been so kind during this
stream that's that's true let's get
ourselves copyright clearances
all right here we go here we go back
into the youtube
john answer some questions here all
right you are annoying popsicle
thank you oh oh we got a can who are we
i see his people who need to who are we
blocking who's popsicle let's block
he was still ook sauce in the dark side
that's a good point in the flashback
oaks thank you thank you who's popsicle
the only
the only uh uh gripe about that
i i have the add them is moderate
i'll add popsicles to moderate the only
no no i'm not doing that guys i can't i
did i just hit him i just hit him i
can't articulate
as well as i someone brought up a
nitpick with that sequence and it was
the one thing where i was like oh that
is a good point about them being like
this was the one place we lost and we
and we lost the omega drive
with that and all that stuff so how did
they not know the omega drive then would
would be on earth where they couldn't
attain it and
everyone vanquished them and it was the
only world they hadn't been able to
conquer you know like
like that's one nitpick about that
sequence we're like yeah fair
but him losing like yeah it makes
absolute sense because he still looks us
and
you got [ __ ] zeus and people yeah you
know you got yeah he's in there man
aries and and that was cool that's
another like little not necessarily a
low-key moment that was another cool one
where i was like
damn once upon a time aries was key in
saving the world yeah you know so like
even the recontextualization there would
be would be rad
oh boy we are so fine it's okay it's
okay
we must power it through we will do this
we can do it we we are
so prepared oh wow we got popsicles
we're gonna do this we're gonna got only
good vibes we got only good bucks we got
[ __ ] to talk about oh my god
we're caught up we're kind of deborah
snyder okay we're good
we're good all right let's do this let's
do this i appreciate this guys because
you guys are keeping the conversation
alive and reminding me
the things you forget about feeding on
your energies we did talk about that
all right cool we did talk about that
oh chris suspense is killing me oh pizza
sounds great
uh uh okay here we go we're around here
racism was the last one okay racism was
the last one the leftover racism left
off on racism
the last of the racists pandemic jones
what's up
i missed you guys we missed you pandemic
thanks for being here i don't know what
has been asked yet uh but i just want to
say that i loved every minute did not
feel like four hours to me
what were your guys favorite moments i
loved everything cyborg
i mean i feel like we've kind of touched
on all of our favorite moments
throughout this live stream so i'm
trying to think of another moment here
that i really love that we did not
really talk about yet
barry and the puppies was hilarious uh
uh
i liked you know what i thought there
were a lot of no one's brought up alfred
today
but shouts out to jeremy irons even
though i feel like he maybe gets pared
down a little bit by the snyder cut i
still loved his scenes and his
presence throughout especially you know
him and bruce on getting out of the
plane
that scene they added back in where he's
talking to him on the runway and
whatever before they you know
fly back faith alfred yeah that was a
great scene actually i loved that when
he got
really alfred got really excited about
the plane starting to work
yeah this whole movie they've been
working on this plane together on that
detail of like it wanted to fly
actually yeah let's talk about outfit a
little bit we haven't talked about it
because i
i do really love how um there's a
fliparoo here
where bruce is so goddamn cynical in bvs
and alfred's the one who's just trying
to get him to be a little bit more
positive
a little more human yeah and then this
one alfred is so cynical about this
whole process
yeah he's like i don't think you know
maybe a guy in the cave is not the one
to unite the team
are you sure you want to do this lex
luthor had some thoughts all right
okay you got the team together you did
it but do you really want to resurrect
superman alfred's mephisto he is always
playing
devil's advocate there was one scene i
really love that is
might not feel essential but it's it's
another thing that i think
fleshes out the character and makes it
feel more human when he's working on the
gauntlets to uh block
you know beams and [ __ ] and uh he's
black panther gauntlets
he's talking with wonder woman and then
wonder woman wants to make
tea or coffee i think yes she's making
tea
alfred she's like i know i can make it
and alfred doesn't want any but no
matter
micromanaging the tea time he's just
micromanaging the tea
because it's like it reminds you that oh
yeah this guy was originally a [ __ ]
butler
and she offers him a cup and he's like
nah i'm good i don't i don't want
whatever you're making right he doesn't
do like any butler things
it's just it's all the the man in the
chair things yeah
yeah um yeah so i think a lot of like
the alfred stuff is great
i love i just like he's the one who
objects against superman showing like
should we really get superman
yeah and i love that moment with ben
affleck being like um
it's like you shouldn't wave the red
cape at it but would you read the when
you wave the red cape at this one
he charges back yeah
[Music]
justice for outward at least the alfred
cut jose velazquez hey guys love your
videos just watched the sounder code
yesterday and they should have released
this also just saw the first episode of
falcon in the winter soldier
man i gotta say i like i love falcon in
the winter soldier i really do
i'm excited i don't care about it but
damn what a week for it to get
overshadowed
people have been demanding for years
like
like it's doing great like it's still
doing great falcon don't get me wrong
falcon the windshield is still doing
great but i think we have we gotta face
some facts
it's zack snyder's weekend definitely
being overshadowed by cider cut
yeah and maybe next weekend we'll see
like by episode three
falcon will be back on time um
niraj krishnan hey niraj we give this
version a seven out of ten enjoyed
cyborg character a lot more i know i'm
in the minority didn't need the martian
manhunter cameo like we've discussed
throughout this stream there's parts
about it that felt like setting up
cliffhanger
setting up for sequels there's other
parts about it that i really did love
overall
i'm glad it was here for the payoff
because we might not have been able to
ever see
zack snyder's martial manhunter brought
to life we might not be able to see him
continue on that's the
reality there's like the reality is we
might or we might not yeah
you know yeah so it's like might as well
in case this is his only shot to feature
martian manhunter
yeah it's like in that scenario where
it's like i don't know if we'll ever do
this again
just put your dream list right here you
know yeah it's like you could take him
out in the movie wouldn't really change
but i'm happy to have him
eric morrow nothing thanks
those are the best kind of super chats
no thoughts on this got nothing to work
off of here yeah i appreciate that eric
mara
eric morrow will get it back to us on
the morrow with a comment
d rock mortal kombat snyder cut
everything is for that's the thing now
is a great mortal kombat movie though
i mean it would look awesome it would
look amazing and with the slow-mo would
be the good place for you to be able to
get half naked sonia blade
actually feel like it's not sexist
we've come a long way from sucker punch
i feel like he'd be able to pull
that movie doesn't pass that test he
would be like whoa
you get like the buffest ass sonia blade
i would
i would love to i could count on him to
cast that way
some reason we cast supermodels to play
sonia blade and you have them train for
a couple months
where he would get like a buff-ass sonia
blade i really wish that president would
be more
because yeah like ah it's such an
upgrade like jack
which wrestler do i like let's get here
yes yes
yes um kenneth rathbun junior
unfortunately wb will do the ball drop
the drop the ball on mr michael i say
and lose all momentum of this success
that's the sad part man this is the
exact position wb did not want to be in
this is a hundred percent this is why
they went to all that effort to sync
this movie the first time this
is 100 the position they did not want to
be in
they did not want they were wrong the
world to be like
you were [ __ ] wrong yeah brother you
don't know what you're doing this is
100 and oh my god
were they wrong like this is so wrong
it is incredible how wrong they were
this has got to be
really weird at wb right now because
you have they have the most anticipated
thing on earth right now in godzilla vs
kong and also the biggest eat crow
moment on earth right now with justice
league
like and then you also have things like
mortal kombat it's like there's stuff
that they have that everyone's psyched
about but this is like such
a big loud obvious like what were you
guys
thinking this whole time like everything
about the comparison process of these
two
cuts seems to come back to what was even
the
philosophy of the weeding cut from your
guy's perspective
and with the knowing how much wb
interfered by how vocal
zack snyder and ray fisher have both
been it's just like wow wb this is this
really
this is really your fault man this is
true bad decision bad leadership
[ __ ] but no i'm really excited
for godzilla versus kong still
i'm so excited for some [ __ ] in the
heights let's do this
wb wp is very good to us wwe has been
great to us
but also this was embarrassing you guys
[ __ ] us up
this was embarrassing for them and hey
walter hamada man i wonder how he feels
today
um damn two new godzilla clips dropped
did not know about it
maybe we'll put him up tomorrow film it
put up tomorrow
i am willing not sleep never sleeping um
thank you matthias we'll look it up sir
we'll look them up uh sylvester fryson
jr
what's up guys what's up sylvester
mister live chats what do you think of
junkie sl soundtrack for the snyder cut
i mean we've touched on it quite a bit
throughout the stream and i gotta say
that
yeah if you want the best experience of
it go on a drive listen to it work out
listen to it so many different sounds
pull out a bunch of emotions
we've talked pretty in depth about it
throughout the stream so yeah
um but i appreciate you chiming in here
oddly jones what would you want in a
sequel if it happens
okay look up the storyboards of what's
supposed to go on in justice league two
and three
look that [ __ ] up and then i just wanna
see
that brought to life i wanna see exactly
what he had laid out brought to life
that's in some museum in dallas right
now i think
um i want to see that one brought to
life those are the versions we gotta get
like just look it up you can like geek
just google it you'll find it
my answer is nine words a film by zack
snyder
co-directed by joss whedon let's do that
bring them together you know what i
gotta say what i'm hoping for that
happens i hope they bring back chris
tario the writer
and i hope chris tario gets some more
recognition for his script
i feel like everyone everything around
this movie has gotten recognition but
christario
yes when he [ __ ] wrote this epic and
he wrote bvs
um he like he co-wrote it he deserves
a lot more recognition for his writing a
bit let's let me [ __ ]
write this [ __ ] out especially for a
four-hour movie like this to be as
coherent as it is i mean no small part
and thanks to the script absolutely like
everyone's getting praise right now um
not everyone
but a lot of people around this movie
are getting praise
but chris theriault is not i don't see
anyone praising chris tario and he
deserves respect can we get chris tario
in the stream
can somebody call someone called chris
is he hanging in a ben affleck's house
writing his next movie
yeah yeah he's he's writing a batman
script in silence
um release the bat flick cut well i mean
yeah small face in the chat right now is
saying that it's changed a lot since
those story boards were made
but i want anything akin to that i mean
it seems like they definitely had
this movie is laying the foundation for
what those storyboards had within them
so while i would be
almost certain that under these
circumstances things would change
uh yeah it seems clear that this is like
a vote of confidence in the zack snyder
vision so if he's already got it mapped
out further then i guess that's
the way to go i guess what i would say
like to be a little more clear
is to have the build-up to the nightmare
uh
apocalypse on earth really see that real
life and really get to live in that in
the third part where it's a big battle
to take on darkseid
yeah and get back superman you know like
yeah that's
that's what i would want it's like if
anything has to stick it has to be
the build to that is what has to stick
yeah
oh dude can you imagine the nightmare
scene has to pay off yeah the two
nightmare scenes have to pay off gotta
get your
your apocalypse like evil heroes world
going
and i gotta say too one quick thing in
the nightmare scene that we got which is
all a reshoot that zach just did on his
own looks [ __ ] great
yeah blends with the movie blends with
the whole movie it looks amazing
like the background landscapes i'm like
goddamn there's a reshoot yeah
yeah i mean maybe that's where some of
those finishing funds went
uh sergeant cymek in the future i want
to hear just once
meanwhile back at the hall of justice
yeah that'd be cool
hey they got the table and they got six
chairs
i mean we guess we some goddess i think
what we would need for a sequel speaking
of
back at the hall of justice what we need
for a sequel for a part two
is for it to really feel like they are
the justice league team that does
assemble at this table
the justices league of america they need
to feel like the justice league
and then they need to have the despair
and the darkness for the third one
with the apocalypse and all that but i
think if you were to do a part two
that one at least half of that you got
to feel like oh this is them united
working as a team that bands together
now being a team is our sort of state of
being or state of resting
exactly you know you need to be able to
have that that [ __ ] the table that
has the jl on it
you know wow man hey they hinted at it
it's coming
i want that heroic feeling throughout
kind of like
i mean i'm going to reference the joshua
like kind of like age of ultron what
they were trying to do
at the beginning of that yeah but yeah
done well
um uh chase gardner hey chase how's it
going bud
um hi greg and john watch the zack
snyder justice key justice league cut
loved it
i want henry cavill to come back as
superman do you want man of steel sequel
or a movie with a full nightmare
superman movie
i mean if we can get both that'd be
great if we can get like a proper man of
steel too that would be incredible yeah
i find it kind of funny how superman
this uh how we talked earlier in the
stream how this is superman's arc
yet the more the movies progress
the less he's in this i know yeah
which is fascinating because especially
the end of the snyder cut it does feel
like yeah
this is the sort of formation arc of
clark
of superman more so than clark
and yeah it almost feels like now might
be an appropriate time to do a man of
steel too or we can check in on him now
in the sort of more traditional lane
that we know
him from lane puns
and have it you know yeah take place
post this and take place in a world
where he is just established
as superman now like i don't know
after this build up it does feel to me
like
bvs and justice league are in their own
ways also sequels
directly to man of steel right uh so
yeah
i i guess while uh
a justice league with a full-on
nightmare superman seems a little more
natural coming out of this i think it
would be cool to kind of zero back in on
the one character now you know
especially after such a checkpoint as
justice league feels
i mean that's what i mean though it's
like i feel like zack snyder has a
future with hbo max
and i think i think like if they wanted
to do another man of steel
on hbo max people would tune in sure
yeah and then when theaters are opening
you can start doing your limited
releases one day we're going to get the
steiner cut on imax and you best bet i'm
going to be there
oddly jones is the berry iris stuff
cannon for flash
it is cute it's supposed to be they're
bringing back the actress for uh who
played iris west which might actually
get a line of dialogue
well and i've i've i know there's debate
but in our comment threads i've heard it
say that like you know they
wanted aquaman to be a sequel follow-up
to this version
and not to the joss version uh so
i guess yeah it seems certainly like it
would be canon now
especially if she's gonna be here i have
a british accent then that's a great
question
yeah where's her british accent maybe
they figured that since
wanda could do it mira could do it i
love how volkow just seems like
so much more tragic in this one yeah and
desperate
and and like god damn it why won't you
take up your mother's trident
because we out because as of this movie
we haven't seen him doing this for years
this is just like his everyday life just
like completely getting on my [ __ ]
nerves i made a pledge that you would
take up the mantle dammit
i am supposed to be he's supposed your
teacher
you the initiative love the mcu but the
director driven films of dc joker snyder
cut badenson are
extra inspiring to me they make me more
enthused about the genre
a hundred thousand percent you know like
i love the variety that the dceu offers
because as much as i'm in love with the
snyder verse i love a lot of the films
that are not
part of the snyder verse specifically i
mean
birds of prey technically is and we're
champions for birds
[Music]
so yeah i mean like i i do love the
variety of it and the
i guess the quick question is like can
they start really doing this with
characters who are not as
popular not as familiar you know what i
mean like we got like
jokers and batmans and you know and
might now have
multiple supermans but can they pull off
more of these like i want to see them go
down more villain paths
one one story i've always wanted to see
done is a scarecrow stand alone yeah yes
a jonathan crane movie yes um like
there's so many different fascinating
origins with the guy i think you can do
a great jonathan crane movie
and but yeah that's a big part of why i
love the dc right i think that's what
makes them separate is the fact that
they got
these multiverses that are already
connected yeah and i feel like there's
something to
to to that i don't know there's
something to that about having
a a a wider i don't know i feel like you
could do almost like a rogue's gallery
anthology and incorporate jokes right
various others
like that like i feel like the dc eu
regardless moving forward
there's a lot that's guided by and based
on what zack snyder
envisioned for everything however uh
because they aren't necessarily doing
exactly what marvel is doing
i do think yeah you have a nice
opportunity to really
get some filmmaker driven films that
could fit into an overall more loose
continuity that maybe has
you know your justice league man of
steel stuff the more traditional
characters that are your
main sort of timeline that we're
following but then yeah embrace the fact
that you don't need to do so much
interconnectivity or find a different
way to yeah explore and to keep
what the original thesis of the dceu
was which was filmmaker not committee
driven films and like to watch as
wb has abandoned that idea so many steps
along the way is fascinating but but
yeah
i i would love to uh to get more of
those director driven side
uh and less known character films cause
like that's the big another big hurdle
that i feel like dc
in the movies hasn't crossed as much as
like marvel has brought in a lot of like
oh damn
this character who now everybody who's a
layperson has to learn about
you know i feel like the closest we've
gotten so far in an obvious way is like
martian manhunter now is some people are
going to be like oh damn who's that
um so yeah i'm even there he's been
explored in other mediums already
yeah absolutely lily aguilera
thank you for your super chat the
initiative thank you lillian
but there's like nothing here so we love
you too the initiative
hope marvel takes the cue from the
snyder cone and aspire to longer movies
maybe even some straight to streaming
flicks
i mean that's their series i i feel like
their series of marvel yeah
are already straight already straight to
streaming flicks already some some
people already make the mistake of
calling them films
like and they kind of serve that purpose
to fit in with the films
and they keep going like it's a six hour
movie you guys falcon wears soldiers but
i think dc has a market to tap into and
speaking of dc i hope they do
more doom i hope more people watch doom
patrol
secondly i'm seeing a lot more people in
this chat right now who actually
like birds of prey way more than i
expected guys
[ __ ] yeah we talking about that's why
you're here with us
that's why you're here with us some
people don't as i'm seeing some comments
too
but one alberto martinez
oh dude you have such a lovely name and
we're gonna do it justice
i missed it
thank you saludos right back
day america the initiative i guess i'm
trying to say i'm curious about how the
snyder cut will affect the superhero
genre going forward if snyder could
direct a marvel film which would you
want it to direct i vote fantastic for
i don't want him to do josh train point
two i think i would want him to do
daredevil
he said he wouldn't he would want to do
dairy and when he said daredevil i was
like
he would make a great daredevil who be
here that's about the perfect character
yeah he would do an incredible daredevil
movie zack snyder like
with the religious themes um
the action that would require the the
visual landscape of capturing new york
city's
uh a hell's kitchen you could throw in
so many more music because the character
is blind
yeah i think he would do an incredible
job and doing like the visual
representation of his senses
yes i think zack snyder would do an
incredible daredevil yeah that's a very
natural place to put some slo-mo
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's the perfect
pitch because daredevil allows for a lot
a lot of dark tones but you're not
full-on punisher yet
you know lily aguilera who is your
favorite character
love your videos um well thank you lily
favorite character in this one
it's cyborg and wonder woman yeah
probably those are my two favorites in
this cyborg and wonder woman cyborg and
wonder woman maybe even barry
maybe even you know batman too maybe
even clark
aquaman alfred and kind of like whistle
is actually pretty good they're all
pretty good
no i think it's a pretty solid tie for
cyborg and wonder woman for me in this
one
yeah what are your guys's in the chat or
your favorite character
who would you say your favorite is here
there's a lot of love for barry in this
chat specifically
aquaman most improved player i gotta
i gotta give him that honor there mark
thank you so much for you mark love you
vavi priv um love your reaction guys my
girlfriend makes a big sigh every time i
put on one of your videos so big hello
from her
love from norway oh love to norway well
you just
tell your girlfriend that you're leaving
her
yes dump her ass tell her she ain't
worth it
we don't have enough in common if she
doesn't like the real rejects
what the [ __ ] don't worry most people's
girlfriends most people
don't like that's what makes you part of
the community
that's your girlfriend she's rejecting
you
by not enjoying us say okay stay with
her i even encourage you to marry us
give it a shot love to norway thank you
xx3b
i feel sorry for stepping wolf he just
wanted to go home to his family
you know that's the sad part about the
steppenwolf performance with the eyes
that i was talking about
i feel kind of bad for him because my
dude looks so
sad all the time dude just wants to get
a little validation
from yeah the rest of his family he's
out here trying
he's out here doing a complex operation
getting his hands dirty
oh man i i completely agree with him he
is a womp character
like if he wasn't such a you know evil
character you'd be like
man i feel sad for this game
you can only watch one the initiative
says which would you rather watch
affleck batman film or man of steel two
act like batman film just because we uh
because we don't have a taste
i mean of his true his batman film
deathstroke was not realized and he was
cast for it specifically
we know we have ideas of what batman ben
affleck wanted to do
for his batman film yeah so yeah i think
the batman film undoubtedly is the one
that would most want to see where his
man of steel 2 kind of lives in this
weird ethereal plane of
what it might be like ben affleck's kind
of had a specific vision and and the
script was reportedly pretty damn good
yeah you know so uh yeah i would want to
see the affleck batman film
nash sanadiki joss whedon cut the cyborg
atm scene oh my god what the [ __ ]
right there with you man that has been
one of the most talked about scenes
superman's uh kartik sharma superman's
dad wonder woman's mom shazams wizard
a tribe leader and aquaman and joker and
joker did any gladiator cast member
appear
in snyder cut did any
gladiator cast member
[Music]
oh i get what you're saying the caliph
from the cast of glad
of the film gladiator or just any
not appear in snyder cut is i think is
what i'm trying to say
oh man that's the joke because he's
already answering the question
i said that people have appeared there
are
too many people yes
i think if we just forgot to put the
word did any gladiator cast number not
appear
and the answer is no they know they all
did yeah joaquin's in there
even the actors who have already passed
away they're in there right they're in
there
they're zack snyder cgi them in the
battle man yeah yeah yeah
they live nearby and richard harris is
just wandering around
he's like hey what's everyone fighting
about
want that cut of the movie billy for
shetty
love you guys thank you love you too
what do you guys think about luther
hinting at the legion of doom
you see that's what he hinted at in the
josh whedon cut and he doesn't do that
in this one
he gives him bruce wayne the name of
bruce wayne so that's setting up the
batman film that's why i want the batman
movie
but having the legion of doom i mean if
you could build to that that would be
amazing if you could get that in zack
snyder's justice league
universe that would be incredible i
would absolutely love to see the legion
of
doom realize i mean in some ways that
would be like if you kind of have that
as like your your
second movie threat yeah and yeah then
you bring darkseid back when we forgot
about it
and if you're like doing an exploration
of those characters i feel like like
actually if
zack snyder did like his anti-hero film
like his legion of doom movie
that would be pretty you know what for
an hbo max movie a legion of doomfill
would be a pretty cool way to go that
would be pretty sick
and and more redemption because then it
would finally bring people around to
jesse eisenberg's lex
it's never going to happen it's gonna
happen it's gonna
happen i'm signing i'm starting a
petition
to release the eisen cut um
no cardiff in the in the live stream
just brought up did you see zack snyder
chilling at the shop when lois was
leaving with her umbrella
damn i saw a still image of it no i
didn't
alfred hitchcock cameo levels for sure
yeah my dude he re-shot that scene
yeah just to put himself three shots in
case people don't know who i am i'm just
wondering
in the film brian l this movie was so
good
glad they gave flash and cyborg they're
due i will watch it again tomorrow
hopefully zack snyder does the follow-up
amen to that i'm glad you're kidding
me i'm glad you're in the same page as
us
when he looks at his dad during the
superman scene resurrection scene
when he looks at his dad during the
superman scene resurrection scene
who superman he can't look at his dad
what i thought was cool with the dad
part was when he's walking through the
hall of suits and he's having
the uh echoing voices of both of his
fathers
i have a question about that actually
because in
that sequence paul kent is much more
encouraging of superman
ascending other movies what it's not in
the other movies
yeah and i'm just sitting here kind of
that's always been a thing that even on
rewatch i'm like
this is a very different way to take
podcan and so like that
change round of then having the voice of
encouragement from him was beautiful
in context of the movie but outside the
context i was like this doesn't match
what
with anything pocket said before because
this whole thing before was like don't
even save my life
don't don't don't even intervene i think
as
if honestly the one trope i kind of have
a hard time getting on board with in a
lot of movies and shows is ghost dad
like where they they just they're this
is from their own mind
this projection of ghost dad this is
what i wish my dad would say to me yeah
and i'm like we're really just getting
the advice themselves they're not really
a ghost but they act as if a ghost is
coming to them
yeah and sometimes that trope kind of
bothers me
and it's in bvs when he sees his father
so i think
what that is though is like so much of a
clark has had to deal with
from man of steel is a sense of i think
unintentionally jonathan kent has
instilled a little bit of shame in the
clerk
i think it's very unintentional though
of you have to repress your powers maybe
you should have let those kids in the
on the bus die you know like the
government found out who you are no
don't save my life in this tornado
you cannot expose yourself you know like
hide yourself
hide who you really are um
and i think in that scene with when he
sees his dad on the mountain when he's
isolating
he's starting to see his memories of his
dad in a different light so you when you
cut into the flashbacks of man of steel
it's a lot of shame in bvs it's a
it's light he's starting to see the
light of him and then here it
i don't think paw kent ever said those
things to him
but that's part of his character arc
here is the acceptance
and feeling like he's feeling like that
self-acceptance is kind of this
projection of paw ken's voice
yeah his head like the actual lines of
call of jor-el
but the projection of the subconscious
voice that he has of park kent always in
his mind
of hide yourself to now know embrace
yourself
like that inner voice that he has is
actually
his own voice clark's but it's in the
form
of paw kent's voice yeah so i think
that's what's happening there
it's like embrace yourself fly go to the
sun
charging up steppenwolf murder snapshots
neck boy
thick
that's rewind back time and save me from
that tornado that's why pacquiao did
that because he knew that the second he
encouraged clark he wouldn't be able to
stop
yeah pop culture pot but i really don't
understand zack snyder's vision that's
my
problem no you you are a hater and
that's all that you are
doing to fans is this what you guys want
to hear
yeah is this about saying the right
thing comment below with what you would
like us to say
um pop culture podcast love the actor
playing henry allen
hope he reprises his role in the flash
solo filmed uh what's his [ __ ] name
dr manhattan billy crowd up billy crowd
it's a very fascinating jagger hoover
and that one clint eastwood oh no
love the actor playing uh i know patrick
wilson is writing the dcu but he's my
dream pick for reverse flash
yo patrick wilson would be a great
reverse flash
actually that would be a very [ __ ]
great reverse flash
actually oh my god yeah
it could work in its own weird [ __ ]
way you know
i mean people get there there are
instances across these things of like
people
re-costumed and reworked into other
roles
i mean he he's he's a pretty significant
dc character at the moment but i would
never put it past him
ronan thank you ronan do you think that
we will get a red hood film
next year how great would it be if in
zack snyder's justice league
you find out jason todd is not dead and
he's red hood
that would be a like an unexpected that
hasn't been revealed and that'd be like
a great unexpected reveal but i would
love for red hood to appear
there's so i mean i've again i never
know
unless it's coming out of the horse's
mouth which of these pieces to fully
rest my hat on but people have said like
no no zach was like it's
de grayson who got killed and whose suit
you know had the the spray paint on it
so you know like
you could oh it was dick grayson from
from what i've seen oh i missed that
piece
what i've gathered that's what zack
snyder is purported to have said but if
anybody very
next to jimmy olsen yes gotta get those
those side characters in the cemetery he
keely
i just got the wind knocked out of me i
just need a few seconds that's all then
he saved the friends he told bruce he
needed
that's what i mean it's about like there
is so much heart within zack snyder's
characters that
i don't think give enough credit it's
about this determination this fury
within
this acceptance of thyself like there's
a lot in there and in that moment too
i love that i just did a few seconds
that's all yeah
it was so human and it was one of those
things where like i was getting so
tense and i mean you know like the
stakes are huge and there are pair of
demons and there are guns going and
everything but
him being winded and also having that
wound i i was like
completely wrapped up in because i was
like not only yes is this going to mean
dire things for the plan
but think of that for him like just
being like i need to catch my breath
like it's it's such a human thing and it
was so beautifully done i thought with
him
thomas larson jensen nothing here but
thank you
you are so thankful right some glitch on
youtube's end
i don't think so jose velazquez hey guys
loved your reactions for like four years
watched the snyder cut yesterday
they should have released this also
snyder better get jl2
a hundred percent tell us thank you jose
very much agree and thank you for
watching for so long and thank you to
everyone who's been in this chat
thank you jesus christ people have been
here for so long i really appreciate it
hit that [ __ ] like button
yeah yeah thank you guys so much this
means a lot to have you here seriously
like there's been a blast talking about
this you should just talk about justice
league every life
every channel is the justice league
channel from here on now go back to the
justice league
spoiler review part 5 sorry guys we are
not talking about godzilla who we are
talking no more about
no mortal kombat justice league zack's
nice zack snyder's
1-4 hours is where all the content is
coming from from now on
tom poulton barry's smile as you said
make your this is what like
barry allen is the most honed in on
character
out of anyone and i'm i'm actually i
don't mean this as any slight i
i just wasn't expecting him to be the
most honed in on character here yeah
barry's smile as he said make your own
past makes me think that he realized he
can change time
he got the idea to save his mother
thoughts i think he knew he could change
time i think he was aware of the
capability
he was also he even says there like i
have to break the rule
yeah so i think he knew that he was
already capable of
break of um of uh time traveling and be
able to shape the
shape the world so um i don't think in
that moment he was realizing it i'm
pretty sure he was already
aware of what he can do yeah maybe
that's that's the precedent for the rule
um george kent hey george kent
do you like the joker they used we've
talked extensively about him in this
live stream
but i would say overall what mattered to
me
is that he was better than what we got
in the theatrical cut for suicide squad
i still don't love him
but i liked it i'll say that i liked it
quite a bit and i liked the context of
the scene
and i loved parts of the performance
but i'm not in love with it yet yet
i still liked it all right i gotta make
that clear i liked it wasn't in love
though
it's a good vote of confidence that
makes me go i would be interested to see
this character develop the right way
yes you know and i think under zack
snyder's direction you probably do a
great job
or or david ayer's direction if we could
ever see what that looks
like actually look like right yeah ernie
fertile i'm glad the flash versus
superman speed wasn't a trope
oh this i didn't even get to my one
point that i wanted to make when i was
like there's one point i have to make i
totally dropped the ball on that
um the one point i really wanted uh
something that i felt was missing out of
a four-hour film
um what didn't you get enough of was i
wanted superman
to have a scene where he's just
interacting with the justice league
specifically flash
because superman does flash does say he
was my hero
and i would have liked an actual scene
with just him talking even if it was
short like
20 seconds just something of like hi i'm
clark
nice to meet you yeah like actually now
that we've done all this yeah
you almost could have broken when
they're all standing on top of the wall
then just like
so hi i'm clark especially with how much
aquaman was like this is a
terrible idea yeah [ __ ] this is bad this
so we shouldn't be doing this god damn
it
it's like if there was a moment where
they like shook hands yeah
just that that's all i wanted was like a
shook shaking hands or barry being
nervous to say hi
some kind of yeah like just after the
game is done sort of like yeah
oh hey we can actually kind of greet
each other for a second and rest in the
triumph of work
or superman just being like sorry about
earlier yeah yeah yeah like something
like that
sorry for attacking you guys you know
and like thanks for bringing me back
like that was
one little thing i'm like i wish that
was in this movie like you get the hero
shot
you get him picking up batman but i
would have liked to have seen them
like have like 20 to 30 seconds true
ensemble
group team moment maybe after maybe
after the boom tube
closes because there's one funny moment
to me when like i love the meaning of
the shot
of how the death of superman of
his interaction with superman his turn
of superman brought batman out of his
darkness
and then in the reverse shot of superman
and
picking batman up before you get the
hero shot of them all standing
i'm like why is batman climbing why
didn't superman just think about this
i love the symbolism of the shot but i'm
like yeah it's like one of them
barry can run up the thing cyborg can
fly superman can fly
aquaman might have a little trouble but
yeah bruce is the one who needs somebody
so um but yeah overall oh [ __ ] i'll give
you a boost hold on
doctor hero man i love you guys i love
you too thank you so much for the super
chat butter it's a really cool
big generous one thank you uh
six days of chaos man of steel is
jonathan kent
i wanted you to hit that kid clark glad
you did not how
dare you save a bus of kids be careful
that is steel
yeah that's a very interesting thought
process but i think the establishment of
what we were talking about with jonathan
kent of being the voice
in clark's conscious makes a lot more
sense if you watch
jonathan kenton there and i think kevin
koster does a great job playing jonathan
again i think he does a wonderful job
yeah man
here it is the question i was dreading
william jones mcu end game or zack
snyder's justice league
i don't want to decide this not because
i'm afraid to divide
like uh it's it's like justice league is
just way too fresh in my heart right now
that i would need time to settle with
both
to be like okay when i look back yeah
it's definitely justly
or oh yeah it's definitely end game
right now i just don't know
i don't know and the only way i could
answer this question right now is by
pulling a technicality and going well
justice league is just one film
and end game i don't know if that would
work if you didn't have
the orbs so in that context i'm like
justice league uh but yeah in terms of
actually definitive i guess if you
combine
end game and infinity wars one story
that's a hard one to say honestly
yeah very hard check back you can check
back
back into our heads jv
feature thank you for your super chat
thank you
um galen shumway thank you buddy how
great is the music changes 2017 aquaman
going into ocean throwing down the
whiskey making him look badass
new version the music makes him show he
is alone in that scene not in the best
place
and this is a great example of what i i
put out a tweet that i was saying that
this movie is completely different that
even the scenes that are
reused uh even the scenes that were in
the
justice league they're different here
from the surrounding context and just
from the context within
from the editing style from the pacing
from the choice of music
from the from the lighting from the way
that they're edited
they're all different and i think that's
what's so great like this
this little example right here like it's
such a different feeling emitted
in zack snyder's justice league versus
the justice one
um so yeah thank you for pointing that
out hey this is way more [ __ ] rock
man way more purpose
he's the storm within being personified
by the sea
life of nate we made it live from nate
there's your five dollar super jay
told you two hours later we got there
told you we had to catch up to it
the snyder cut made me actually love
this versions flash and cyborg their
chemistry
is pretty cool with the scenes they
share and what about
martian [ __ ] yeah i mean yeah we talked
a lot about them
this something we haven't talked about
this bums me out that cyborg is now
eliminated from the flash movie
yeah dude because their interactions
together are great and they actually be
being the newbies for this movie and
being the characters this movie has the
most introduction to do
in a way and and there are scenes in
which they do kind of gravitate toward
each other
there's a foundation for them to to
share a movie together like it's yeah
it's so much more of a bummer
i mean the one-two combo punch of flash
reversing time then cyborg going into
the mother boxes and demonstrating that
the only way to save this was them to
having to work together i feel like
within
a lifetime but the time traveling
problem these two working together would
be excellent and with flash being like
i need some friends when he's talking to
bruce and then
cyborg completely isolated himself it
would have been great to get cyborg to
be
in the flashpoint movie but you know
[ __ ]
[ __ ] joss whedon wanted flash to fall
on wonder woman's tits and stuff
yes
which hey i i was gonna make i don't
even have a joke